[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
en direct sur public sénat édition
spéciale ce matin avec la dernière
audition de la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale sur la sphère benalla c'est
sophie at directrice des services actifs
de la police nationale qui sera la
dernière personne à être entendu par les
sénateurs
sofia a dirigé le j espère le groupe de
sécurité de la présidence de la
république sous françois hollande elle
n'était plus en poste à l'arrivée d'
emmanuel macron son témoignage aura donc
ce matin une valeur d'expertisé des
expertises et devrait une nouvelle fois
éclairé à les parlementaires sur
l'organisation de la protection du chef
de l'état alors pour en parler ce matin
m'ont invité à philippe bonnecarrère
bonjour c'est la plantera centriste du
tarn vous êtes membre de cette
commission denquête on va vous demander
dans un instant ce que vous en attendez
mais avant cela on va retrouver ta mme
tran huy ce matin et bien vous êtes
toujours devant le foyer clemenceau
je le disais sophie ah tu n'étais plus
en poste à l'arrivée à des manuels
macron que peut-on attendre de son
audition ce matin oui vous l'avez dit un
sofia très l'ancien chef du fameux gspr
le groupe de sécurité de la présidence
de la république qui est en charge de la
sécurité rapprochée du président de la
république avec le commandement
militaire alors sofia a dirigé la
sécurité de françois hollande à l'époque
elle a dirigé une équipe de soixante
deux officiers de sécurité à parité des
policiers et des gendarmes et
aujourd'hui elle est donc directrice des
services actifs de la police nationale
on attend donc d'elle plutôt un regard
d'expert teint ce n'est pas une
personnalité proche de l'enquêté
puisque vous l'avez dit sofia ce n'était
d'ailleurs plus en poste lorsque manuel
macron est arrivé est devenu président
de la république met d'ailleurs noter
qu'il ya quinze jours cela avait été
très intéressant d'entendre le préfet
michel bénard qui avait lui assuré cette
même fonction notamment auprès de
nicolas sarkozy
reste que ce cycle de près d'une
trentaine d'auditions s'achève
aujourd'hui presque dans la discussion
dans la discrétion avec ce regard
d'expert t on va avoir encore quelques
semaines à attendre avant d'avoir et
bien la vie
et le rapport qui va être rédigé par
muriel jourda et jean pierre sueur après
donc c'est trentaine d'auditions
merci à vous tam philippe bonnecarrère
on le disait c'est donc la dernière
audition le point final de cette
commission denquête qu'en attendez vous
une ultime expertise c'est effectivement
probablement la dernière audition il ya
peu d'intérêt à reconvoquer les
personnes est rentré dans un travail de
tribunal entre guillemets il a toujours
été dit que ça ne serait pas le cas où
on se transformer en des charlots comme
ceux de la place de la contrescarpe
qu'est ce que nous attendons nous
attendons toujours pour le scénar de
prendre de la hauteur par rapport à ces
questions et en même temps d'aller vers
les conclusions il faut savoir terminer
une commission d enquête et avec bien
sûr d'ensemble des collègues nous
examinerons les conclusions possibles
qui a priori ce n'est pas un grand
secret vont tourner autour de ce qui est
aujourd'hui la séparation de pouvoir
dans notre pays et le rôle respectif de
la présidence de la république avec un
sur le rôle éminent politique du
président de la république garante des
institutions mais aussi un gouvernement
qui doit continuer à diriger vers
l'administration s'en va avec une vraie
séparation entre les deux et puis il ya
ce qui est tout à fait légitime dans une
société les conditions de la sécurité du
président de la république est très
prudent mes collègues souhaiteront va
faire des propositions à cet égard ne
sera pas allé au bout de six mois il
aurait pu se prolonger il fallait aussi
en finir absolument très compliqué pour
le chef de l'état
je crois pas qu'il y ait de l'air entre
une rentrée compliquée la fin de la
commission denquête il faut savoir
terminer les commission denquête il faut
les mener avec un peu de recul avec
sérieuse qui a été le cas je récuse le
lien avec l'esprit politique je sais
bien qu'on peut prêter à toujours à une
commission des formes d'arrière-pensées
mais je récuse fondamentalement l'idée
que cette commission enquête serait un
affaiblissement
de la présidence de la république nous
avons besoin c'est la force de la
constitution de la vème république on a
célébré la semaine dernière avec les 60
ans c'est sa force d'avoir un exécutif
stable et un président de la république
garant de nos institutions
ce n'est pas une atteinte à l'autorité
du président de la république
que dire qu'à des pouvoirs doivent
correspondre des pouvoirs indépendants
et que le sénat est un pouvoir
indépendant non-alignés et il faut qu'il
puisse jouer son rôle c'est bon pour nos
institutions c'est bon pour notre
président de la république ne serait-ce
qu également pour un motif
supplémentaire c'est qu'avec le chant le
modification du calendrier électoral
sonné lien président de la république et
dans les trois semaines qui suivent on
lui donne sa majorité ne serait pas
épargnée dans les conclusions de cette
commission denquête écoutez je ne crois
pas que ce soit l'objectif de la côte de
la commission il pourra peut-être y
avoir un débat là-dessus je répondrai
pas sur des murs en ce qui me concerne
je vois cette commission comme un
travail indépendant du sénat je vous
l'indiquais pas une recherche
affaiblissement du président la
république mais au contraire un jeu
normal des institutions pour moi un
président il sera est d'autant plus fort
qu'il a à ses côtés des possibilités
expression indépendante et c'est la
spécificité du sénat l'assemblée
nationale et élu finalement sur le
programme du président de la république
ce n'est pas le cas du sénat il fait de
faire son travail indépendant je ne dis
pas que ce serait peut-être excessif
c'est un hommage à la présidence de la
république sait mais c'est une manière
de respecter profondément son rôle et je
ne vois donc pas en tout cas à titre
personnel je j'essaierai d'aller en ce
sens je ne vois pas là de schémas
d'affaiblissement de l'autorité du
président de la république au contraire
vous avez les réponses à toutes vos
questions puisqu'on sait que de
nombreuses zones d'ombré persistent
notamment sur ce qui vous occupez ce qui
était au coeur de cette commission
denquête le rôle précis joué par
élections dans bénin alors vous dire que
nous avons eu toutes les réponses
provenant pas ce garçon qui a par
ailleurs été charmants lors de
son audition ne nous a pas effectivement
tout dit je ne peux pas dire qu'on soit
convaincu par tous les éléments mais je
pense que sur ce sujet il ne faut pas se
polariser sur des détails où il ne faut
pas se polariser sur une logique de
contradictions dans qu est ce qui est
important c'est encore une fois de
prendre du recul de regarder les choses
globalement et de faire des propositions
et faisant des propositions de sortir de
cette commission denquête par le haut
pour tout le monde à mon avis pour
l'exécutif mais pour le sénat et ses
vis-à-vis de mes collègues c'est sûr sur
quoi je militerai sur une commission d
enquête qui sort par le haut par la
qualité des propositions positif est à
nos institutions et assurant aussi la
transparence à l'égard de nos
concitoyens ont parlé d' alexandre
benalla ça a été le point fort un de vos
travaux à titre personnel quel a été le
fait marquant de cette commission
denquête qu'en avez-vous retenu
moi je ne suis pas sur des questions
personnelles ou des questions
d'immédiateté je crois que notre vie
politique est vraiment mise en cause par
l'immédiateté cette personnalisation ja
presse une forme de discrétion
j'apprécie justement c'est ce sérieux
qu'a pu avoir le c dans le travail et
donc je ne donnerai pas la personne ne s
y gilles ysos de red hot en ce qu'il
faut à mon avis que les conclusions
soient généralistes portant sur la
sécurité du président de la république
ils font bon fonctionnement de nos
institutions mais en se dégageant de
toute considération personne je crois
que ça vaut pour les uns pour les autres
pourtant au fil des auditions on a vu
quand même une histoire s'écrit recèle
un fonctionnement particulier de la
machine élyséenne depuis l élection d'
emmanuel macron bien sûr mais chacun va
en avoir sa lecture
mais il va falloir se réunir sur des
conclusions et sur des propositions et
le faire des propositions le fait de
faire des propositions à la fois sur une
meilleure articulation du fonctionnement
de nos institutions comme sur des
conditions optimum de sécurité pour le
président de la république ne paraît pas
porter atteinte à l'autorité de
quiconque m le rôle normal d'un sénat
indépendant force de proposition et
représentants des citoyens dans le
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement et
de l'action de l'exécutif chacun est
dans son rôle
est ce qu'il ya pu y avoir des parures
pendant cette commission denquête on
rappelle qu'elles sont passibles de
poursuites
je n'emploierai pas des grands mots et
je pense que ce serait une erreur
même si à l'évidence on peut avoir le
sentiment de quelques contradictions
je crois que personne ne gagnerait à se
transformer en détective privé ni
sherlock holmes dire qu'une pouvoir vous
prendrez la référence que vous voudrez
mais par contre acteurs d'un bon
fonctionnement des institutions
oui pour notre commission commission
enquête qui aura été utile il ma
carrière je crois en tout cas la réponse
dépendra de la qualité des propositions
de leur caractère opérationnel et de ce
que j'appellerais leur caractère positif
il n'y aurait aucun intérêt à mon sens
sous réserve de l'avis de mes collègues
à faire des propositions politiques
je n'ai pas senti ce travail comme ça et
à titre personnel je ne souhaiterais pas
pour la dignité du sénat et plus
généralement pour la qualité du travail
public qui est par ailleurs qu'elle même
questionné par nos concitoyens
je pense qu'on veut tous faire attention
à la qualité des propositions d'un
caractère positif parce que l'audition
de sofiane débute à l'instant absolument
philippe leuba a qui s exprime et on se
retrouve tout d'abord merci je voudrais
vous dire que si le programme de nos
auditions s'achève avec cette audition
nous avons entamé avec les rapporteurs
et nos collaborateurs de la commission
des lois un travail d' analyse
approfondie de l'ensemble des
déclarations que nous avons accueillis
pour mettre en évidence les points
qu'ils ont pu d'ores et déjà être
éclairci les contradictions qui
ont émergé de nos auditions les réponses
que nous avons déjà mise en évidence sur
ses contradictions et celles qui
subsistent
c'est un travail très important compte
tenu du volume de la matière que nous
avons reconnu recueillies et qui va donc
se poursuivre encore quelques semaines
et peut justifier de nouvelles demandes
si nous avons besoin de complément par
ailleurs les rapporteurs et moi même
avons écrit un certain nombre de
ministres ou d'institutions pour
recueillir des informations
complémentaires et répondre à des
interrogations qui sont nées des
auditions qui ont déjà eu lieu
notre travail donc se poursuit même si
ces modalités comme il est naturel
évolué si bien que les informations qu
ici ou là pourrait paraître selon
lesquelles nous sommes en phase
d'achèvement sont évidemment tout à fait
excessive
même si le caractère spectaculaire que
parfois les les médias ont donnée à nos
travaux et évidemment en train de
s'atténuer comme il est légitime mais ce
qui nous permet d'ailleurs de poursuivre
notre tâche dans une sérénité qui ne
nous avait jamais abandonner un métier
naturellement de mise pour approfondir
les différentes questions qui sont
soulevées et qui pour la plupart d'entre
elles ont très bon fonctionnement de la
sécurité du chef de l'état dans un pays
dont il ne faut pas oublier que c'est la
cinquième puissance du monde et que
cette sécurité présidentielle
est une affaire qui concerne tous nos
concitoyens et qui justifient bien que
le parlement s'en préoccupent si des
dysfonctionnements comme nous avons pu
le constater
elles sont apparues pour faire des
recommandations et améliorer ainsi les
garanties apportées au pays et au
président de la république par
l'organisation et le bon fonctionnement
de sa sécurité
je vais maintenant me tourner vers
madame hat et lui dire comme nous
l'avons fait pour toutes les précédentes
auditions madame qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission des lois
doté des prérogatives d'une commission
denquête serait passible de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amendé
je vous invite madame a prêté serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
levée s'il vous plaît la main droite et
dit je le jure
si vous le voulez madame vous pouvez
introduire cette audition par un propos
liminaire ce qui n'est nullement
obligatoire mais ce qui peut nous
permettre déjà de recueillir un certain
nombre d'informations et de témoignages
de l'expérience que vous avez eu comme
chef de la sécurité présidentielle
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
bonjour je effectivement j'vous je vais
prononcer quelques propos liminaire pour
vous rappeler le parcours mon parcours
professionnel qui peut éclairer votre
connaissance de
qui peut expliquer les raisons pour
lesquelles je suis hors jeu aujourd'hui
devant vous je suis donc commissaire de
police depuis 27 ans j'ai occupé
différentes fonctions à la préfecture de
police ainsi qu'à la direction générale
de la police nationale
à mes débuts j'ai été là dans l'ancêtre
de la démo pc puisque la démo pc est un
acronyme que vous connaissez bien
mais en 1993 se lasser taxe appelée la
direction de la sécurité publique de la
préfecture de police
donc j'ai tout d'abord été en charge
j'ai tout d'abord été nommé attaché du
2e district en charge de maintien de
l'ordre
principalement j'ai ensuite été
commissaire adjoint du 15e
arrondissement puis commissaire du 3e
arrondissement
la direction de la sécurité publique est
devenue la direction de la police
urbaine de proximité puis plus tard
deviendra la direction de l'ordre public
et de la circulation
j'ai occupé des fonctions de commissaire
central du 3e arrondissement jusqu'à la
fin de l'année de 1999 et en 2000 le 2
janvier 2000 j'ai été nommé chef du
groupe de sécurité du premier ministre
c'est à dire j'ai assuré la sécurité du
premier ministre
de 2000 à 2002 j'étais en charge de la
sécurité de lionel jospin
j'ai assuré la sécurité d'un premier
ministre devenu candidat à la fin de la
fin de demie de 2002 ensuite j'ai quitté
le service de la protection des hautes
personnalités parce qu'il se dénommait
comme cela à l'époque il est devenu
ensuite le service de la protection
je suis j'étais en charge ensuite de
renseignement à marseille puis adjoint
du coordonnateur des services de
sécurité intérieure en corse
je suis revenu à la préfeture de police
en 2010 et j'ai eu différentes
différentes affectations pour être
ensuite nommé le 29 mai 2012 chef du
gspr donc chef du groupe de sécurité de
la présidence de la république
j'ai occupé ses fonctions jusqu'au 5
mars 2017 et donc dans à peu près cinq
années j'ai assuré la sécurité du
président de la république françois
hollande à la tête du gspr qui selon les
souhaits du président de la république
recoupé des fonctionnaires de police et
des gendarmes
c'était son souhait après un historique
que vous connaissez le groupe de
sécurité la présence de la république a
été parfois composée très
majoritairement de policiers parfois
très majoritairement de gendarmes et le
présent la réplique françois hollande
lorsqu'il m'a reçu ma expressément fait
connaître sa volonté que des gendarmes
réintègre le groupe de sécurité de la
présence de la république soit quoi bien
évidemment j'ai obéi et j'ai composé le
gspr à partir de fonctionnaires de
police issu du sphp puisque c'était le
sphp à l'époque le service de protection
des hautes personnalités et de gendarmes
issus du gign
voilà ce groupe de sécurité de la
présente présence d'un public était
composé de soixante deux officiers de
sécurité uniquement des officiers de
sécurité
j'ai quitté ses fonctions le 5 mars 2017
pour être affectée est dirigé depuis la
direction de la coopération
internationale au ministère de
l'intérieur
merci beaucoup chère madame de cette
présentation nous allons maintenant vous
poser un certain nombre de questions
la première que je souhaitais vous poser
concerne les recrutements est-ce que
c'était vous qui possédiez au
recrutement des gendarmes d'élite et des
policiers d'élite qui était affecté au
gspr à leur évaluation éventuellement
est-ce que c'était vous qui décident y
est de mettre fin à la collaboration ou
était ce les services de protection du
ministère de l'intérieur
tout à fait c'est moi qui ai
personnellement recruter tous les
officiers de sécurité qui ont fait
partie du j'espère qu'ils les aient noté
et qui les ai remis à disposition à
quelques très rares occasions lorsque
leur comportement ou leurs performances
ne convenait plus au niveau requis pour
faire partie du j espère je vous
remercie dans les règles de forme de
fonctionnement du gspr l'entraînement
l'évaluation est ce que ces règles
étaient fixés par vous directement où
elle était déterminée par le ministère
de l'intérieur
lorsque les gendarmes et les policiers
ont été recrutés par parmi soins au sein
du gign au sein du sdlp il avait subi
des tests pour partie pour faire partie
de ces unités
donc il était totalement au niveau en
matière de compétences professionnelles
en matière de sécurité rapprochée
l'entraînement était au sein du gspr
assurée par un moniteur et sekope
collaborateurs disposant de toutes les
qualifications et l'entraînement était
constant au sein de l'unité parfois à
l'extérieur dans des sites extérieurs
qui étaient mises à notre disposition
par la gendarmerie nationale ou la
police nationale etiez-vous tout à fait
autonome de dans les décisions à prendre
pour la sécurité présidentielle à
l'occasion des déplacements ou
aviez-vous une autorité qui vous imposer
un certain nombre de décisions de
sécurité
j'étais totalement autonome en rendant
compte de manière permanente de tout
incident de toute difficulté à la
directrice de cabinet puis au directeur
de cabinet puisqu'il était devenu ma lin
directeur de cabinet et ensuite
a été remplacé par un directeur de
cabinet très bien et dans les
déplacements qui étaient directement en
contact avec les préfets les directeurs
départementaux de police nationale les
colonel commandant le groupement de
gendarmerie pour assurer la coordination
entre votre propre responsabilité et
l'organisation de la sécurité sur la
voie publique dans les bâtiments cette
coordination est cette coopération se
faisait sur le territoire français en
métropole comme outre-mer en coopération
et en collaboration constante entre le
ou la chef de cabinet puisque là aussi
l'homme la mandature a commencé avec un
chef de cabinet qui est devenue une chef
de cabinet de manière totalement clair
puisque le secrétaire général de
l'elysée avait organisé ce
fonctionnement par une note qu'il a
signé au début de la mandature donc
l'organisation générale était de la
compétence du chef de cabinet mais tout
ce qui concernait la sécurité rapprochée
et la sécurité rapprochée était de ma
compétence exclusive mais la compétence
générale était une coopération entre la
chef de cabinet ou le chef du cabinet et
moi même je vous remercie est ce qu'il y
avait un collaborateur du chef de
cabinet particulièrement dédiée aux
affaires d'organisation de la sécurité
absolument pas
je vous remercie quand vous observez les
photos et les vidéos qui montrent
monsieur benalla auprès du chef de
l'état à l'occasion de déplacements
diriez vous que sa présence à l'épaule
du chef de l'état était caractéristique
d'une activité de protection rapprochée
les quelques images que j'ai pu voir
d'un collaborateur du président de la
république au plus près de lui ne me
semble pas signifier qu'il avait une
mission de sécurité rapprochée dans tous
les déplacements d'un président de la
république il est fréquent que un
ministre un collaborateur une autorité
préfectorale ou étrangère un ambassadeur
un autre président soit au plus près de
lui
cela ne tient pas à sa compétence ou sa
qualité en matière de sécurité
rapprochée mais le déroulement de la
visite nécessite souvent qu'une
personnalité soit au plus près du
président la république je vous remercie
madame jourdain
merci monsieur le président merci de vos
réponses madame je voudrais revenir sur
une déclaration de monsieur b dallas et
vous demandez quelle votre opinion si
toutefois vous en avez eu sur cette
déclaration
monsieur b dallas en indiquant qu'ils
étaient effectivement présents on le
voyait présent l'épaule droite ou à
l'épaule gauche de président de la
république nous a dit c'est
effectivement un changement
la fonction de nos fils de sécurité
n'est pas de porter des dossiers le
manteau du président c'est être attentif
et de le protéger en permanence c'est
effectivement un changement disait-il sa
présence aux côtés du président de la
république voyez vous un changement dans
les quelques images que vous avez pu
voir donc jeu
en fait je vais répéter mes propos parce
que je vous je voulais dit il est très
fréquent qu'une autorité quelle qu'elle
soit collaborateurs ou aux préfets ou
ambassadeurs ou autres ministres soient
au plus près du président de la
république
je confirme qu'il n'est pas n'appartient
pas à la mission des officiers de
sécurité de porter des dossiers ou de
porter les manteaux ou les écharpes
donc je ne vois pas la confusion les
officiers qui ont été n'ont jamais été
fait pour remplir cette mission
parfois certains collaborateurs ou
autorités sont très proches et les
officiers de sécurité un des officiers
de sécurité rapprochée sont parfois
obligé avec le plus de courtoisie
possible et parfois avec moins de
courtoisie quand les éléments sont quand
nous sommes sur un salon dans un congrès
où quand il ya eu beaucoup de beaucoup
de monde
parfois nous nous chahutent on et je
m'en excuse auprès tout ce que nous en
plus chahutés pendant les cinq ans
j'étais chez du j'espère mais nous
chutons parfois et je vois certaines
personnalités ici qui ont fait les frais
parce qu'ils étaient parfois très proche
d'un présent la république parce que les
les circonstances l'imposaient mais il
appartient aux de l'officier de sécurité
de reprendre sa place auprès du
président la république lorsque les
conditions donner c'est de sécurité
l'imposent jourdas comment et assurer la
sécurité du président la république sur
les déplacements privés
elle est assurée de la même façon que
sur les déplacements officiels mais de
manière plus discrète c'est à dire que
les officiers de sécurité s'adaptent
dans leur tenue vestimentaire déjà
adopté à peu près la même que celle du
présent d'un public lorsqu'il est
habillée de manière décontractée et les
dispositifs sont souvent moins lourd
parce que la discrétion fait partie
également de la sécurité
je voudrais revenir sur une image que
chacun je pense a vu ici il vous même
également qui était celle du président
de la république monsieur macro qui
faisait du vélo et qu'ils étaient suivis
à quelques centimètres parce qu'on ne
peut pas dire maître par monsieur par
monsieur bénin où est censé se trouver
l'officier de sécurité dans ce type de
déplacement
j'ai effectivement vu une photo en
revanche le champ était n'était pas très
large et j'aurais aimé aussi pouvoir
disposer d'un champ plus large pour vous
expliquer aux hôtes et les officiers de
sécurité parce que je n'étais pas sur le
dispositif et donc ne peut pas subodorer
leur position mais je pense qu'ils
étaient dans une proximité totalement
raisonnable drogba ou les auriez vous
placer assez près pour pouvoir
intervenir c'est la sécurité du
président était en jeu merci de cette
réponse madame hot madame jourda
monsieur sur l'île madame la directrice
madame le chef vous avez des réponses
précises et bien cadré vraiment cela
nous fera que je voulais vous demander
ceci à votre connaissance quand vous
étiez dans cette fonction à l'elysée il
y avait des personnes du cabinet du
président de la république qui disposait
d'un port d'armes
à ma connaissance il n'y avait pas de
proches ou de membres du cabinet de la
présidence de la république qui
disposait lors de mes fonctions sous le
quinquennat de françois hollande de port
d'armes
à ma connaissance merci je voulais vous
demander si que il vous paraît peu
crédible qui existe un groupe de travail
que pour eux mieux coordonner le gspr et
le commandement militaire
je n'en ai aucune idée je voulais vous
demander eux
si et pardon mes chers présidents sûr je
vous cite la réponse de madame att
laconique mais pour aller plus loin dans
cette direction
avez-vous a eu à faire l'expérience de
difficultés entre le groupe de sécurité
de la présidence de la république et le
commandement militaire
justifiant de placer entre les mêmes
mains
les deux services
parce que il y aurait eu 100 cela des
failles dans l'organisation de la
sécurité du président je n'ai rencontré
aucune difficulté durant cinq années à
travailler en collaboration avec la
garde républicaine à la fin de fin le
colonel général désormais bio-farina
commandé la garde républicaine nous par
travaillons en pleine coordination sans
jamais aucun incident et cette
coordination ne justifiait pas
l'existence d'un coordinateur lors de
mes fonctions lorsque j'étais chef du j
espere cela ne le nécessitait pas je
vous remercie monsieur sûr merci
vous savez sans doute lu dans le journal
du dimanche une déclaration de monsieur
benalla je cite pratique entre
guillemets nous avions contre nous au
ministère de l'intérieur peu par rapport
à un projet dont on peut supposer qu'il
était quelque peu porteur où il était
impliqué dans ce projet qui aurait
consisté à mener une réflexion pour
réorganiser la sécurité du président
bart des hautes personnalités de telle
manière que celle ci fûtes autonome ou
plus autonomes ou est une certaine
distance à l'égard du ministère de
l'intérieur
quand vous avez lu cette phrase entre
guillemets dans le journal du dimanche
quelle a été votre réaction
je n'ai pas lu le journal du dimanche
en revanche j'écoute vos propos
il ne m'inspire pas de réflexion
particulière parce que je ne vois pas
pourquoi le ministère de l'intérieur
aurait été contre une réforme
pourquoi les propos de monsieur benalla
n'évoque pas pour moi de difficultés
particulières à penser à rendre un
service plus performant et plus efficace
depuis le début de la vème république
les personnes qui gèrent la sécurité du
président de la république sont des
fonctionnaires qui dépendent soit du
ministère de l'intérieur soit du
ministère de la défense et à ma
connaissance il n'y a jamais eu sauf
peut-être dans la période récente
d'idées de les autonomiser par rapport
d'une certaine façon par rapport au
ministère de l'intérieur
qu'en pensez vous lorsque je commandais
le gspr tout en étant formellement
appartenant formellement au ministère de
l'intérieur
les pères personnel du j'espère était
placée sous l'autorité la présidence de
la république
pour preuve durant les cinq années où
j'ai été chef du j'espère je n'ai jamais
été noté par ma hiérarchie au sein du
ministère de l'intérieur et vous ne
rendez pas compte au ministère de
l'intérieur de ce que vous faisiez
notamment de l'organisation des
déplacements privés du chef de l'état de
l'organisation des déplacements privés
absolument pas parce que cela fait
partie de la vie privée du président de
la république
en revanche je me suis ouverte à
quelques reprises à ma hiérarchie de
difficultés dans l'organisation ou de
suggestions à pour améliorer
l'organisation du fonctionnement du
j'espère est ce que vous pourriez nous
citer dans ce cas quelques difficultés
qu'il y aurait justifié que le ministère
de l'intérieur on discute avec vous
enfin le ministère de l'intérieur pour
être très précis c'était le directeur du
sphp je lui ai fait part de difficultés
sur
le comportement ou les compétences de
certains officiers de sécurité qu'il
allait falloir que je change que je
renouvelle donc je lui ai expliqué les
raisons mais qui sont des raisons de
service totalement classique il en a
pris acte et et voilà c'était simplement
du fonctionnement interne on sait
président sur le fait qu'ils se soient
passées celui qui s'est passé le 1er mai
et qu'il n'y ait pas eu de
comptes-rendus d'aucune sorte ni au
préfet de police ni au ministère de
l'intérieur le soir même vous paraît-il
de quelque chose de normal
là vous me demandez de m'exprimer sur
une maison à laquelle j'ai appartenu
il y a quelques années le le compte
rendu est une au sein du ministère de
l'intérieur et de très nombreuses
administrations et le mode de
fonctionnement normal et habituel
surtout lorsqu il y à des évènements
particuliers
le compte rendu et parfois orale pas
forcément écrit tout dépend également de
la gravité des événements donc je ne
peux pas simplement je vous rappelle les
règles mais vous les connaissez bien
mieux que moi donc je pense que les
choses ont été faites de manière normale
mais je n'ai pas d'appréciation
particulière à la silly à une réunion de
commandement qui comporte le ministre de
l'intérieur le préfet de police et
d'autres personnes eux qui fixent la
capacité pour des personnes de
participer à cette réunion
une réunion présidée par le ministre
c'est le cabinet du ministre qui
détermine qui sont les participants à
cette réunion
de la même façon pour le cabinet du
préfet de police et d'autres autorités
chacune à leur niveau sont leurs
cabinets qui le déterminera une dernière
question parce que je peux pas vous je
pense que vous répondez très très
précisément je tiens vous le dire vous
n'avez sans doute pas vu vos hautes
fonctions au ministère de l'intérieur et
la coopération internationale du travail
vous n'avez sans doute pas pu visionner
les 29 auditions auxquelles les 28
auxquels nous avons participé
vous pourrez tout à fait dans vos
loisirs si si vous le souhaitez les
regarder mais lorsqu'on les regarde
attentivement et que l'on met les uns à
côté des autres
les témoignages faits sous serment il
peut apparaître que monsieur benalla
était un organisateur de voyages en tant
que chef adjoint de cabinet il peut
apparaître qu'il était un garde du corps
ou quelqu'un qui assure et de fait une
sécurité rapprochée notamment dans les
voyages déplacements privés il peut
apparaître qu'il était doté d'une sorte
de mission de confiance à caractère
général
il peut apparaître qu'il n'avait aucune
mission de sécurité
aucune ça nous a été dit sous serment il
peut apparaître qu'il avait des missions
de sécurité qui consistait non seulement
à coordonner la sécurité et à coordonner
les différents s'amuse sécurité avec
d'autres services et encore de réfléchir
en prospective
quitte même à donner des instructions à
certaines personnes de la police et de
la gendarmerie
quant à une évolution future de la
sécurité et de l'organisation de la
sécurité du chef de l'état je vous dis
cela parce que peu tout ce que j'ai dit
ici est attestée par des déclarations
publiques faites sous serment tout y'a
pas un mot qui ne l'est pas ce qui
montre le travail je puis de précis une
petite parenthèse comme l'a dit très
justement notre président philippe bas
le travail qui est devant nous pour
trouver finalement la vérité notre
intime conviction
c'est notre rôle les dysfonctionnements
donc par rapport à cette énumération que
je viens de faire
quel est votre sentiment ou et des
commentaires à faire c'est ma dernière
question je vois sur ses rapporteurs
main sur le jeu ne peut malheureusement
vous parler que des cinq années durant
lesquelles j'ai été chef du j espère les
choses étaient clairement établie
j'étais en charge de la sécurité
rapprochée du président de la république
le chef puis la chef de cabine est est
en charge de l'organisation des
déplacements
notre travail de collaboration a été
extrêmement clair je ne me suis jamais
chargé d'organiser les déplacements du
président et un public
il ou elle ne s'est jamais chargé
d'organiser la sécurité rapprochée du
président la république
elle n'aurait pas où il n'aurait pas
accepté que je je je je je sois sur son
domaine de compétence et je n'aurais
jamais accepté que quelqu'un prenne
place sur le mien cette dernière
observation est évidemment très
importante je vous en remercie madame
jourda une dernière question pour moi
aussi madame précisément basé sur votre
expérience au sein de l'elysée quelle
est l'attitude du président de la
république dans l'organisation de sa
propre sécurité
aucun texte ne prévoit que le présent la
république doivent se soumettre aux
responsables de sa sécurité
je ne dirais pas que cela je ne porterai
pas l'appréciation à l'absence de textes
durant cinq ans le présent la république
enfin le présent applique a choisi que
je sois le chef de son groupe de
sécurité de manière prétentieux je
dirais qu'un lien de confiance est créé
entre le président de la république et
moi même j'ai parfois dû lui expliquer
des dispositifs assez particulier j'ai
parfois attiré ça sent la tension sur
des déplacements qui pouvait être à
risque je pense plutôt à des
déplacements à l'étranger
tout ceci se faisait en collaboration
constante avec le direct la directrice
puis le directeur de cabinet
parfois je remontant jusqu'au secrétaire
général de l'elysée en lien également
lorsque c'était à l'étranger avec le
chef d'état major particulier et nous
formions une équipe dans la gourde au
sein de laquelle ces questions de
sécurité qui touchait la personne même
du chef de l'état était discuté et je
n'ai jamais eu à déplorer de mésentente
ni à accepter en matière de sécurité
rapprochée des dispositifs qui ne me
semblait pas convenir à la sécurité
rapprochée du président la république
autrement dit madame le chef de l'état à
cette époque ne se dérober jamais au
dispositif de sécurité tels qu'ils
avaient été convenues entre lui et vous
non j'ai assuré pendant cinq ans la
sécurité du président la république
et lorsque j'ai quitté mes fonctions son
intégrité avait été préservé
heureusement je vous remercie
nous allons maintenant mes chers
collègues passer aux questions que vous
voulez soulevé la première inscrite et
madame benbassa
ce qui m'interpelle
vous avez été chef du groupe de sécurité
de la présidence de la république lors
du quinquennat de françois hollande
quelle aurait été votre posture
vis-à-vis d'un chargé de mission du
cabinet de la présidence porteur d'une
âme
est-ce que parmi les membres de l'elysée
d'autres personnes que les membres du
commandement militaire ou du j'espère
pouvait et disposer d'un port d'armes
madame hot je remercie de cette question
adam
aucun membre comme je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure aucun membre du cercle rapproché
ou en tout cas de du cabinet du
président république ne disposait de
port d'armes
lorsque j'ai été chef du gspr au plus
près du présent d un public seuls les
officiers sécurité du gspr et lors des
déplacements à l'étranger
les officiers de sécurité des services
étrangers puisque la souveraineté du
pays fait c'étaient eux qui étaient en
charge de l'art et de la sécurité du
public et seuls des officiers de
sécurité rapprochée de certaines
d'autres autorités françaises membres du
gouvernement ou ancien président de la
république
seuls eux pouvaient être dans un cercle
rapproché du présent d'un public mais
aucune autre personne armée madame je
vous remercie madame lherbier monsieur
le président madame vous avez souligné
que vous aviez 62 officiers de sécurité
et vous avez bien souligné uniquement
d'autant plus que ces 60 de personnes
n'étaient particulièrement traîné comme
vous nous l'avez précisé pouviez-vous
connaître d'une existence quelconque
d'un personnel tels que monsieur
benallal si ça s'était présenté ou est
ce que c'est
ce que ce que je veux dire c'est vous le
dit officiellement mais par hazard
pouviez pourriez vous être sûr qu'il n'y
avait personne d'autre
ça c'est ma première remarque la
deuxième cieux benalla nous a dit il se
sentait en insécurité et c'est pour ça
qu'il avait demandé à port d'armes
qu'auriez-vous fait madame si vous aviez
appris que quelqu'un se sentait en
insécurité auprès du président de la
république et enfin troisième remarque
si vous me permettez
il y à de nombreuses vidéos quand un
événement tel s'est passé quand il ya
des des risques concernant l'ordre
public il y à de nombreuses vidéos en
amont êtes vous au courant de tous les
les possibilités d'enregistrement vidéo
en amont ou est ce que c'est par la
suite que vous découvrez que healy à tel
et tel camarades qui pourraient servir à
une preuve quelconque d'un agissement ou
d'un fait qui se serait passé
merci m pour répondre à vos attentes
pour répondre à votre première question
comment peut-on savoir que quelqu'un est
armé c'est cela si vous l'êtes vous le
dit tout d'abord le port d'une arme
n'est pas quelque chose de discrètes
en tout cas pour les professionnels
lorsqu'on était professionnel on voit
tout de suite quelqu'un à moins que ce
soit vraiment une arme très dissimulé
mais le port d'une arme fait est
apparent pour quelqu'un qui le sait donc
simplement en voyant la façon de marcher
à ceyrat même même furtivement de
quelqu'un on voit s'il est armé ou pas
donc ça c'est là que la réponse à votre
première question vous me dites que
monsieur benalla vous a déclaré être en
insécurité
il s'est trouvé durant le quinquennat de
françois hollande que certains de ses
conseillers et je me souviens d'un
précisément c'était monsieur hulot à la
fin dans les derniers mois de la demande
de la présence de françois hollande
monsieur l'eau devait faire un
déplacement
dans une dans la région parisienne dans
un climat un petit peu houleux mais je
ne me souviens pas exactement du thème
du déplacement ni de la date
donc j'en avais parlé avec le directeur
de cabinet et à sa demande
j'avais demandé à l'un des officiers de
sécurité du gspr d'assurer la sécurité
de monsieur lors de ce déplacement
donc c'était un officier de sécurité du
j espère donc que monsieur benalla se
sentent en insécurité
je ne sais pas il ya une différence
parfois entre le sentiment d'insécurité
et l'insécurité réelle mais je ne
connais pas ni la vie professionnelle ni
elle ni même monsieur benalla pour
pouvoir donner un avis sur ce sentiment
d'insécurité est ensuite étions et
sommes nous au courant des caméras les
caméras ne sont pas la préfecture de
police est doté d'un très grand nombre
de caméras mais un smartphone est une
caméra en soi et tous nos agissements
passe et son fils mais son film abl donc
je pense que le comportement doit être
exemplaire quel que soit le lieu que
l'on sache qu'il ya une caméra ou qu'on
ignore aucun smartphone soit caché ou
tendue au bout d'un bras aucun
agissement ne peut rester secret très
longtemps ce monsieur président pour
alors madame à verbier permettez vous
nous de préciser je voulais savoir ça
pour la procédure d' alerte vous
constatez un fait particulièrement
répréhensible que se passe-t-il qui est
alerté dans l'immédiate et comment ça se
passe que ce soit c'est pour ça que les
caméras fixes et ça doit être quand même
plus facile que des smartphones mais une
caméra fixe constate quelque chose
comment ça se passe qui est alerté au
plus vite
est-ce que vous pouvez m'expliquer à
quelques à vous pensé pour que je manque
clairement ce qui s'est passé dans les
fermes et nahla comment qui a été
informé au plus vite de troubles qui
pouvait y avoir sur place jusqu à quel
échelon
cette information remonter mais là vous
me demandez lors d'une manifestation
là vous me demandez de m'exprimer sur un
domaine qui n'est pas de celui de la
sécurité rapprochée
vous me demander de me positionner comme
si j'étais partie intégrante de la
préfecture de police
bon jeu madame a répondu je vous
remercie monsieur richard n'a pas encore
été question dans cette audition
à propos du rapprochement discuter du
gspr et de du commandement militaire
mais il me semble bien il me semble bien
que ceci est mentionné dans un rapport
de la cour des comptes qui a été
effectuée à la demande de la présidence
puisque c'est je crois
sous la présidence françois hollande que
les comptes mais l'exécution des budgets
de la présidence est entré sous le
contrôle de la cour des comptes et qu'
il a été fait mention rapport de la cour
des comptes a dressé à la présidence de
république qui recommandait d'éviter des
doublons me semble-t-il principalement
en matière logistique entre le gspr et
le commandement militaire
je ne sais pas à quelle date a été faite
ce rapport de la cour des comptes mais
je pense qu'il serait un élément utile
monsieur le président je pense que ce
rapport serait un élément utile l
enquête est donc est il déjà en
possession de la commission
sinon il me semble souhaitable de le
demander et pouvons-nous y avoir accès
et madame
avez vous été questionné par le
rapporteur de la cour des comptes sur
ces sur ces sujets de charges précis
proc de l'art du gspr et du commandement
militaire imad hamad
j'ai reçu à trois années successives je
crois les rapporteurs de la cour des
comptes qui m'ont effectivement
interrogé questionné sur le
fonctionnement les frais de
fonctionnement les investissements le
coude différentes postes de travail du
j'espère donc à trois reprises en
revanche je n'ai jamais été questionné
par ses rapporteurs
sur un rapprochement éventuel ni sur un
avis que j'aurais pu donner sur un
proche mais l'éventuelle en tout cas ce
rapport à peut-être été fait lorsque
j'étais j'espère mais il ne m'a pas été
communiqué et le cabinet du président la
république ne m'a jamais fait savoir
qu'un rapprochement de serait à l'étude
ni devrait être étudiée il faut
d'ailleurs préciser qu'il s'agit d'une
partie du rapport public d'un rapport
public et que ça ne porte pas sur des
défaillances qu'il y aurait pour la
sécurité présidentielle mais sur des
mesures d'économies et de bonne gestion
monsieur kerrouche merci monsieur le
président madame pendant une des vidéos
qui sont disponibles désormais on voit
lors du salon de l'agriculture que le
président de la république reçoit reçoit
9 et la première la première personne
qui entre guillemets le prend sous son
aile c'est monsieur c'est monsieur
benalla immédiatement en le en lui en le
protégeant
selon votre expérience
cela n'aurait il dit pas eu
est-ce qu'il serait pas dû être le plus
tôt un officier de sécurité qui auraient
dû avoir cette cette attitude
merci madame brad le salon de
l'agriculture c'est un des déplacements
sur le territoire métropolitain les plus
compliqués à gérer lorsque l'on est chef
de la sécurité d'un président de la
république parce que outre les animaux
les oeufs et les journalistes
c'est dans cet ordre madame le nombre de
personnes ou d'animaux enfin voilà la
pression est extrêmement importante
autour du président de la république
ce déplacement fait l'objet d'une
mission préparatoire comme tous les
déplacements mais d'un dispositif très
particulier parce que le prêt en un
public et est entouré également outre du
ministre de l'agriculture du président
de la fnsea du président du salon de
deux différentes autorités plus
protocolairement importantes les unes
que les autres
certaines plus susceptibles les zones
les unes que les autres et tout voudrait
ces personnalités l'a assuré quasiment
la sécurité du président de la
république donc les dispositifs sont
très importants en collaboration et en
coopération constante avec le préfet de
police et ses effectifs puisqu'il y as
pour assurer la sécurité de présenter un
public dense et dans ses autres dans ces
cas là plusieurs zones une zone de
sécurité très rapprochées une zone plus
éloignée plus et d'autres zones qu'ils
sont assurés en coopération avec les
effectifs du préfet de police et des
renforts de du gspr il se trouve qu'à
certains moments le plus proche dans une
bousculade totalement in organisé
peut-être un collaborateur du président
de la république ou le prêt ou le
ministre de l'agriculture et nous avons
comme mission d'assurer la sécurité du
président la république mais l'oeuf est
effectivement un objet qui peut être
lancée sur le présent la république ça
n'est pas le plus dommageable lorsque
leur soit sauf pour le costume mais il
fait partie du cercle des projectiles
possible est vraiment love c'est quelque
chose que l'on se sente sens d'en rire
c'est quelque chose que nous redoutons
lorsque j'ai assuré la sécurité de
lionel jospin du premier ministre lors
d'un salon de l'agriculture
il avait enfin c'est les offices de
sécurité qui avaient reçu l'ofs
parce qu'ils avaient écarté le premier
ministre juste avant
l'arrivée du tiers mais j'avoue que
c'est un déplacement très compliqué si
monsieur benalla à écarter l'oeuf ou a
reçu le fcz je n'ai pas vu exactement
les images je pense que c'est parce
qu'il était dans le cercle le plus
rapproché
l'essentiel c'est que l'offre n'ait pas
atteint le président de la république je
vous remercie madame nathalie delattre
merci président madame à ce que vous
pourriez nous décrire votre mission
actuelle dans le cadre de cette mission
avez vous eu à rencontrer monsieur
benalla comme chef à la chefferie de
cabinet comme chargé de mission à la
chefferie de deux cabinets parce qu'il
semble connaître beaucoup de monde
où l'avez-vous rencontrée dans un autre
cadre puisque là aussi il semble
rencontrer énormément de personnalités
étrangères madame attribués et national
je n'ai jamais rencontré monsieur
benalla ni lorsque j'étais chez du gspr
ni depuis que je suis directrice de la
coopération internationale au ministère
l'intérieur ni sur le territoire
français nés à l'étranger puisque je me
déplace effectivement beaucoup à
l'étranger
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer le
président république lors de cérémonie à
l'elysée et lors de déplacements à
l'étranger mais en tout cas je n'ai pas
reconnu monsieur benalla puisque je ne
le connais pas donc il était peut-être
dans l'entourage mais je ne l'est pas
officiellement je n'ai pas vu et je ne
le connais pas je vous remercie madame
mercier merci monsieur le président
madame la directrice nous avons compris
que monsieur benalla exercer tout un tas
de fonctions qui des missions très
différentes les unes des autres qu'il
exerça avec une forme d'autorité aussi
il est en est une qui nous semblent
pertinentes
il a été déclaré qu'il faisait
l'interface entre l'intérieur et
l'extérieur c'est-à-dire qu'il a mené le
ressenti d'une manifestation et c'était
vraiment extrêmement intéressante pour
les services il faisait part de
l'ambiance qui régnait lorsque vous
exerciez ses fonctions de chef du gspr
aviez-vous des personnes qui vous donner
ce genre de renseignements ou pas est-ce
que cela vous semble intéressant que ce
soit confié à une personne en
particulier la map
non je n'avais pas de il n'y avait pas
de capteur d'ambiance je ne sais pas
comment comment mais transmetteur
d'ambiance comme comme vous l'avez dit
en revanche bien évidemment je disposais
de toutes les informations nécessaires
pour prévenir un incident qui aurait pu
émailler la sécurité d'un dispositif de
sécurité rapprochée et ce via le
directeur de cabinet la directrice et le
directeur de cabinet du pont de la
république ou via le centre national du
renseignement qui est également placée
au présent la république donc tout tout
éléments d'ambiance qui réellement ait
pu avoir un impact
mettez transmis par le biais du cabinet
du président la république je vous
remercie madame harribey merci monsieur
le président vous avez dit madame je
reprends vos moules à proximité d'un
collaborateur ne signifie pas missions
de sécurité et vous avez ajouté qu'il
était coutumier d'avoir des
collaborateurs au plus proche du
président de la république
existe-t-il une
des éléments de formation de ses
collaborateurs de qui 1
répondent à qui répondent dean ou est-ce
qu'ils ont une totale liberté de
comportement
je ne pense pas que les collaborateurs
est une formation particulière en
revanche un dialogue constant entre tous
ses collaborateurs tous les membres du
cabinet susceptibles d'accompagner les
déplacements du président république
parce qu ils tous les collaborateurs ne
l'accompagnent pas c'est souvent des
collaborateurs en mai en fonction de la
thématique du déplacement qui sont sur
le déplacement du président la
république et le chef j'ai enfin je les
connaissais tous donc c'est un dialogue
constant et parfois un peu viril pour
leur expliquer que leur place dans
certains moments sensibles n'est pas à
cet endroit là n'est pas au plus proche
du président de la république
mais le président d'un public lui-même a
parfois besoin de ses collaborateurs
parce que lorsqu'il est questionné il a
besoin d'une indication très technique
et ce ne sont pas les officiers du
j'espère qu'ils sont en mesure de la lui
donner
oui je pense qu'une des difficultés de
votre tâche c'est que le président de la
république est comme un aimant qui
attire à lui est de plus près possible
de nombreuses personnes surtout en
déplacement
monsieur du rhin
merci monsieur le président madame dans
le cadre de vos fonctions entre 2012 et
est il déjà arrivé que des membres du
cabinet le chef de cabinet vous demande
d'interpeller où tout y est des
journalistes ou qu'ils le fassent
eux-mêmes hmad hammad
ça ne s'est jamais passé
il a en revanche parfois été nécessaire
d'écarter des journalistes trop pressant
ou trop encombrant avec leur matériel
leur caméra qui gênait un déplacement
mais à aucun moment je n'ai eu à
interpeller ni d'initiatives ni sur
ordre un journaliste je vous remercie
madame d'euromédis merci monsieur le
président madame la directrice je
voulais vous poser une question
concernant la sécurité du président de
la république bien entendu monsieur
benalla nous a déclaré qu'il avait
obtenu un port d'armes parce qu'il était
lui-même en insécurité
est-ce qu'il est logique qu'une personne
qui est en insécurité soit aussi proche
du président de la république est ce que
sont l'insécurité n'est pas une
insécurité pour le président de la
république à la mode
je ne pense pas que l'insécurité soit un
concept contagieux des personnalités
étrangères extrêmement menacée ont
parfois été au plus près du présent de
la république lors de la marche qui a
suivi les attentats
le 11 janvier 2015 je me souviens par
exemple que le présent la république
était entouré de personnalités
étrangères extrêmement menacée et je ne
pense pas que ce soit cela qui est créé
davantage d'insécurité pour le présent
de la république
merci il n'y a pas d'autres questions
mais chaque look si madame di folco
pardon cher collègue sam prix merci
monsieur le président madame la
directrice génome et que vous nous avez
dit que votre groupement comprenez
soixante deux officiers donc soixante
deux officiers de sécurité sous le
quinquennat de monsieur hollande jamais
noté que sous le quinquennat de monsieur
sarkozy il y avait entre 90 et 100
officiers de sécurité
j'ai noté également que sous le ce
présent quinquennat il y à 74 76
personnes donc d'aider chic assez
fluctuant est-ce que d'après vous le
fait qu'actuellement il y est
72 74 personnes nécessitent que ce
service de sécurité soient complétées
par des chefs de missions attaché à la
chefferie de cabinet et c'est parce que
finalement c'est un peu ce qu'on s'est
un peu ce que j'ai compris quoique étant
donné que les effectifs étaient
relativement réduit il fallait compléter
par d' autres personnes alors êtes-vous
sous ce que le quinquennat de monsieur
hollande des effectifs étaient encore
plus réduit il y avait t'il des
personnes qui complétait votre service
de façon entre guillemets privées note
alors le dimensionnement du gspr a était
fluctuant sous la vème république qui ne
s'appelait pas j'espère à certaines
époques
je crois que je crois que sous françois
mitterrand ils étaient 150 mais les
fonctionnement diffère d'une mandature à
l'autre et cela dépend également du
nombre de personnalités qui sont
protégées autour du président de la
république parce que la sécurité
rapprochée du président de la république
qui est prévu par un arrêté ne désigne
pas le nombre de personnalités qui
doivent être protégées autour de lui son
épouse sa maman ses enfants que sais-je
à d'autres époques qu'elle était
peut-être très nombreuses les
personnalités
donc cela tient beaucoup au nombre de
personnes de l'entourage du président
implique parce que la sécurité de ses
proches influent ou l'insécurité influe
également directement peut influer sur
la sienne
les renforts du j'espère lorsque je les
commande et nous disposions de renforts
qui étaient des renforts de la crs une
c'est à dire l'unité de républicaines de
sécurité qui ne fait pas de maintien de
l'ordre mais qui est uniquement dédié à
renforcer le service de la protection
ce sont les seuls renforts outre des
renforts des services de police locaux
ou de service de police de la préfecture
de police mais qui n'ont pas de missions
de sécurité rapprochée
il n'y avait pas d'autres renforts que
ces renforts dont je viens de vous
parler
aucun or en renfort non professionnels
non policiers ou gendarmes
monsieur ce coin et madame swing les
prix madame si un des collaborateurs de
l'elysée avait fait la demande d'un
permis de port d'armes
en tant que chef de la sécurité
auriez-vous été avisée première question
et seconde auriez vous pu poser votre
veto si vous jugiez inutile dans la mare
je pense que j'en aurai été avisé par la
directrice puis par le directeur de
cabinet du président république puisque
nous avions un dialogue constant et que
lui même savait très bien que seule la
sécurité était assurée par le j'espère
et mettre un veto juridiquement je ne
pense pas que je n'aurais j'en avais la
possibilité
en revanche il n'aurait jamais été
inclus dans le dispositif de sécurité du
gspr je vous remercie madame dribblait
merci monsieur le président je
souhaitais vous poser une question
madame concernant la garde rapprochée du
président de la république dans ses
déplacements privés
vous avez dit que ne s'est jamais dérobé
non monsieur hollande à l'ensemble du
dispositif que vous mettez en place
monsieur benalla nous disait que sur les
déplacements privés du président de la
république
sa présence était quasiment
indispensable puisque et vous nous
l'avez dit le l'encadrement du président
est un peu allégés
monsieur le président françois hollande
avait fait des déplacements très
particulier dans un cadre très privé qui
a été médiatisé je ne porte aucun
jugement sur c'est sûr c'est sur cette
situation mais il était toujours
accompagné d'un officier de sécurité et
il me semblait que c'était un garde du
corps officiels
donc ma question est la suivante dans ce
cadre là cet
cet accompagnement par un officier était
suffisant à vos yeux et ne nécessitait
pas la présence d'un conseiller
particulier et c'est aux côtés du
président de la république madame at il
y a toujours eu des officiers de
sécurité du j espere auprès du président
de la république pendant cinq années
x parfois lors de déplacements privés il
y avait un engouement ou un ou plusieurs
membres de son cabinet mais c'était un
souhait du président de la république et
ça se faisait de manière totalement
coordonnée avec avec mes services merci
de cette réponse monsieur fichiers oui
merci monsieur le président madame vos
réponses sont extrêmement précises mais
du coup je dirais qu'elle augmente le
flou que l'on perçoive sur le rôle de
monsieur benhadda et j'ai cru comprendre
d'ailleurs qu'il était important d'une
oreillette pendant les déplacements du
président de la république je veux
savoir à quoi servait cette oreillette
si vous saviez vous c'est n'a pas de
relation avec les services de sécurité
ai je voulu savoir aussi si certains des
membres du service de sécurité du
président public du gspr avait eu à se
plaindre auprès de vous du d'un
comportement exagéré de monsieur b
dallas dans la proximité qui présentent
leur public
monsieur le président sur le droit fil
de ce que dit monsieur fichés
2 il nous a été donc dit que il y avait
des bulles des réseaux quoi et qu' il y
avait une bulle numéro 1 dans laquelle
il y avait les personnels police
gendarmerie assurant la sécurité
rapprochée quatre personnes peut-être un
peu plus damas et une autre à bulles
plus large il y avait différentes
personnes qu' à différents titres
participer au déplacement et monsieur e
il nous a été dit que monsieur benalla
relever de la bulle numéro 1 de celle
qui était qui concernait les quatre ou
cinq personnes assurant la sécurité
rapprochée
quand vous vous êtes très observatrice
parce que et si oui quelqu'un qui arrive
là monsieur kader n'a pas n'a pas
d'armes
puisque oui le regard des marchés
quelqu'un bon je n'en sais rien mais je
ne pense pas mais est ce que quand vous
regardez les images
ça vous paraît crédible qu'il fasse
partie de cette bulle numéro un où ça
vous paraît comme ça une déclaration
bizarre et pour finir il y avait-il deux
bulles de votre temps allez-y madame
tout d'abord pour répondre à votre
question sur l'oreillette effectivement
j'ai observé que monsieur benalla
disposer d'une oreillette
je ne sais pas si vous avez eu
l'occasion de poser la question de
savoir à quoi elle était reliée parce
que c'est l'essentiel
voilà avoir une oreillette c'est bien ça
se trouve elle est reliée à rien où elle
est reliée un canal qui tlet intéressant
de connaître sur le canal du gspr
lorsque j'en étais là chef
seuls les membres du gspr plus les
renforts de la crs une comme je voulais
10 étaient reliés à ce ce réseau qui est
crypté donc il n'est pas accessible par
d'autres que ce que les membres du j
espère
ensuite sur votre question sur le se
plaindre du comportement de bnl de
monsieur benalla pardon je suis parti le
5 mars 2017 j'espère donc je ne peux pas
répondre à cette question
monsieur monsieur le rapporteur vous
m'avez parlé de deux zones et de et de
bulles effectivement il ya plusieurs
bulles vous les avez raison la première
bulle est composé d'un triangle de
sécurité de trois officiers du j'espère
qu'ils sont au plus près chacun a une
mission à aider des tâches totalement
défini ensuite en fonction des
circonstances et de la dangerosité il
peut y avoir plusieurs bulles mais la
première bulle n'est composée que de
trois officiers de sécurité
donc si quelqu'un est au plus proche
il est inséré dans cette bulle mais ce
n'est pas parce que vous êtes inséré au
plus près que vous avez une mission et
seules ces trois officiers sécurité ont
une mission de sécurité rapprochée
merci de cette réponse monsieur le
président de canet madame a tout d'abord
heureux de vous retrouver puisque je
tiens à témoigner sous serment je n'ai
jamais été molesté par vous dans les
déplacements auxquels j'ai pu nombreux
auxquels j'ai pu participer avec le
président de la république françois
françois hollande ma question elle est
peut-être un petit peu difficile pour
vous je suppose que vous avez suivi de
très près ces auditions que vous avez
entendu les témoignages de monsieur
benalla de l'entourage du président
macron que vous avez entendu de les
questions qui ont pu être posées si vous
étiez encore aujourd'hui la patronne du
gspr comme vous l'avait été pendant de
nombreuses années auprès transfo landes
est ce que les fonctions presse eut
présumé supposé de monsieur ben ali
aurait constitué potentiellement une
gêne pour la mise en oeuvre de votre
fonction initiale à savoir la protection
du président de la république madame had
g et effectivement la patronne du
j'espère pendant cinq ans et cela a très
bien fonctionné parce que
j'ai pu remplir cette mission sans
entrave mais sans entraves techniques
je pense que si quelqu'un avait été
inséré avait voulu s'insérer dans un
dispositif de sécurité
cela m'aurait proposé des difficultés
mais nous là vous faites l'écho de
l'audition de témoignages chaque
audition et chez témoignage bien que
prêter sous serment et subjectif donc
certains parfois aussi peuvent penser
avoir certaines capacités ou compétences
ou délégation d'autorité qui n'ont pas
en réalité
donc je vois là ce sont des suppositions
j'ai eu voilà j'ai pu exercer sans
entrave et cette question ne s'est donc
pas poser parce que chacun était à sa
place vous remercie madame ce sera le
mot de la fin
merci de votre coopération avec la
commission des lois investi de pouvoirs
d'investigation d'une commission
denquête mes chers collègues nous allons
reprendre une activité plus ordinaire
dans un instant nous nous retrouvons
dans la salle de la commission des lois
pour examiner de nouveaux amendements
extérieurs aux propositions de au projet
de loi du gouvernement sur la justice et
donc et le rapport de madame di folco
aussi sur la loi cela la proposition de
loi sur les gens du voyage la séance est
donc suspendu nous nous retrouvons dans
quelques minutes pour l'audition de
sophie at vous avez pu la suivre en
direct sur public sénat probablement la
dernière de la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale sur la sphère benalla alors
va tenter ensemble est bien de dresser
un bilan de ses travaux quels
enseignements
quelles zones d'ombré quelles
conclusions peut-on attendre à présent
de la part des sénateurs mais aussi
quelles conséquences pour le sénat
sortiele réellement renforcée il est
apparu pour beaucoup comme un
contre-pouvoir utile on va bien sûr en
débattre avec mes invités sur ce plateau
j'ai plaisir d'accueillir denis branger
bonjour merci d'être avec nous
professeur de droit public à
l'université panthéon assas paris 2 jean
philippe derosier bonjour bien
vous constitutionnaliste vous est
également professeur de droit public à
l'université de lille et puis alain
marquet merci d'être avec nous un
sénateur à les indépendants de l'aveyron
vice président de la commission des lois
première question pour vous à la marque
puis ce qu'on a vu c'est une commission
particulièrement riche d'enseignements à
titre personnel avez-vous appris à des
choses pendant justement c'est 30
audition et surtout noter les
contradictions de monsieur vinolas qui
notamment pour le port d'armes nous a
dit que c'était pour sa sécurité et
qu'on s'est aperçu en réalité qu'il
portait son arme à d'autres occasions
que pour sa propre sécurité
et puis on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait
des gens qui pouvait s'insérer dans un
dispositif institutionnalisée qu'est le
gspr qui jusqu'à présent n'avait jamais
montré de failles importantes en termes
de sécurité pour le président de la
république et colloques etc à l'occasion
de l'intervention de ce monsieur qui
s'est immiscé dans ce système là et bien
des dysfonctionnements ont pu apparaître
ou aurait pu apparaître et c'est ce que
nous avons essayé de mettre en exergue
au niveau de la commission
vous parlez alors pardon on va retrouver
la nuit pour une réaction du président
de la commission des lois
philippe bas c'est al moussaoui
philippe bas quel bilan faites-vous a
déjà une main de toute cette série
d'auditions a quasiment une trentaine de
puits mois de juillet non mais vous vous
trompez ans n'est pas du tout au moment
des bilans de somme à la 29ème audition
c'est vrai que notre programme
d'audition tel que nous l'avions conçu
s'achève mais un autre travail très
important et qui nous mobilise déjà
depuis plusieurs semaines doit se
poursuivre nous n'avons nous analysons
l'ensemble des témoignages recueillis
des premiers documents reçus nous
demandons des compléments d'informations
aussi bien aux personnes auditionnées
qu'un certain nombre de ministères et
d'audition nous devons faire
l'inventaire des points qui sont
maintenant définitivement et ercis des
contradictions qui restent
pendante des contradictions résolu et
nous avons maintenant à établir ce qui
sera notre conviction profonde sur les
dysfonctionnements éventuels qui ont pu
être identifiés sur la sécurité du
président de la république la france
c'est la cinquième puissance mondiale
il en va de la sauvegarde de la personne
du président de la république bien sûr
mais aussi de la continuité de l'état
dans une démocratie dans un grand pays
comme le nôtre et c'est donc une tâche
extrêmement importante dans le cadre de
notre pouvoir de contrôle qui est même
aussi à devoir de contrôle de l'état
c'est une des deux grandes fonctions du
parlement il ya la fonction législative
il y à la fonction de contrôle et celle
ci est tout aussi importante que la
première et voilà le sens de ce que nous
sommes en train de faire nous avons eu
aujourd'hui de nouveau une audition très
intéressante d'une grande
professionnelle de la sécurité des
hautes personnalités
elle a été en charge de la sécurité du
premier ministre elle a aussi été en
charge de la sécurité et du président de
la république pendant cinq ans et donc
sa parole avait du poids
contredite commence à les faire voler
c'est un travail qui n'est pas simple en
effet et c'est la raison pour laquelle
il est bon que nous le faisions avec les
deux rapporteurs et l'ensemble de la
commission des lois dans un cadre
collégiale pour confronter les points de
vue
et puis aussi quand nous ne ne
considérons pas avoir été suffisamment
éclairé compléter notre information
voilà le travail qui est en cours
il demande du temps et il demande de la
méticulosité demande de la patience et
une très bonne connaissance du
fonctionnement de l'état bien sûr elle
aussi analyser des pièces lesquels vous
manque ton corps a notamment dit que les
la fiche de poste nous a toujours pas
été donnée celle d'alexandre dellal ah
oui vous savez nous avons sur la
définition de fonctions de monsieur dena
la une des versions qui se recoupent en
partie qui sont en partie différente
celle de monsieur benalla celle du chef
de cabinet du président de la république
celle du directeur de cabinet et du
secrétaire général du président de la
république et enfin le reflet en miroir
qu'en a donnée le préfet de police quand
il a attribué à monsieur benalla un
permis de port d'armes au tiff que
monsieur benalla exerçaient une fonction
de police voilà où nous en sommes et le
travail qui continue à se faire je vous
remercie
merci à vous attend pour cette réaction
de philippe bas en direct on accueille
également brigitte lherbier bonjour
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
sénateur et l'air du nord et membre
également de cette commission des lois
et que la commission denquête bien alors
on vient d'entendre philippe bas
effectivement les auditions publiques
sont quasiment terminées mais encore un
énorme travail d'analysé
deux expertises de synthèse
effectivement de toutes ces auditions
qu'en attendez-vous maintenant des
conclusions de ce rapport
alors c'est vrai que j'ai assisté à
toutes les auditions depuis le début et
c'est vrai que tout doucement
une manière de fonctionner se dégager de
deux de ses auditions autour du
président de la république
et comme l'a rappelé philippe bas on est
quand même dans une
dans une dans un pays où on dispose de
deux personnels hyper qualifiés
surentraînés la dame tout à l'heure nous
a dit que sous ses ordres il y avait
soixante deux officiers hyper entraînés
hyper compétent et recruter vraiment
pour leur capacité particulièrement
intéressante et ce qui paraît quand même
troublant c'est qu'une personne comme ça
arrive comme comme ça précipitamment et
qu'on ne sache pas vraiment pourquoi
en quoi elle était importante dans le
dispositif de sécurité
d'autant qu'elle se disait vous l'avez
certainement vu lors des auditions
monsieur benalla se disait en insécurité
c'est pour ça qu'il avait demandé un
port d'armes
il se sentait en insécurité à voir aux
côtés du président de la république
quelqu'un qui se sent en insécurité
c'est quand même bizarre d'autant que
cette dame viennent nous dire que dans
ses fonctions jamais elle a été gêné par
qui que ce soit de ce genre pendant son
son travail de chef du j'espère à
l'époque souvent ce jeu ce pas venu marc
angers cette commission denquête on
lisait a été riche d'enseignements
ça jette une lumière sur l'organisation
de la protection du chef de l'état on a
découvert tout un fonctionnement parfois
un peu inconnu aussi à des vampires
oui ce qu'on peut dire c'est grâce à
cette commission on en sait beaucoup
plus sur beaucoup de choses mais pas sur
monsieur bénard on en sait beaucoup de
plus sur le fonctionnement de l'état sur
la présidence de la république sur
l'organisation de la protection
rapprochée du président en temps normal
mais on ne sait pas exactement quel
était le rôle de monsieur benalla et de
monsieur crasse dans l'entourage précis
du président mais en réalité ça c'est
quelque chose de positif en soi c'est le
travail minutieux c29 audition tout ce
travail de cette commission denquête
elle a enquêté
parce qu'elles n'arrivent pas à certains
résultats en réalité est un résultat
positif
on voit le rôle que ça joue dans la
séquence actuelle de fragilisation voire
de déstabilisation d'exécutif cette
affaire benalla c'est pas une affaire
d'état c'est pas non plus un fait divers
anodin
c'est l'étincelle qui a déclenché la
séquence politique dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons actuellement des
conséquences sur la démission déjà
reconnu jean rozé oui il est
vraisemblable que voilà que gérard
collomb ministre de l'intérieur donc
autorité de tutelle du gspr des forces
de l'ordre soient effectivement pas
forcément une victime collatérale mais
en tout cas sa démission soit une
conséquence de cette crise de la sphère
benalla qui se poursuivent donc jusqu'à
aujourd'hui avec ce remaniement dont
tout le monde parle qui devaient être
annoncées hier matin hier soir ce matin
et qui maintenant on l'apprend ne sera
pas annoncés avant samedi
et même à quoi on veut être le maître
des horloges sentiment qu'il est maître
des horloges cas c'est surtout en ce
moment qui ne marche plus mais ce que
l'on a également appris avec cette toute
cette affaire benalla jeu recentre cette
analyse c'est
quand même un élément particulièrement
surprenant président de la république
c'est le premier magistrat de france la
première autorité publique et politique
de france c'est le chef des armées et
alors qu'il bénéficie d'autorité
spécialisés dans ce domaine le gspr la
gendarmerie la police nationale pour
assurer en sécurité quotidien madame
matelas l'a confirmé dans l'expérience
qu'elle a eue auprès de françois
hollande
il est il décide de faire appel ce n'a
pas été confirmée officiellement mais
c'est ce qui est sous jacent dans cette
affaire à des personnes privées pour
assurer également sa sécurité
je suis désolé mais ça traduit un
véritable dysfonctionnement dans les
systèmes de protection
premièrement il ne fait pas confiance
visiblement aux autorités qu'il est
censé représenter la gendarmerie relève
en partie de l'armée donc il est quand
même
ultime mans leur chef donc ça c'est pour
le moins surprenant et avec tout ce que
cela peut avoir comme conséquences
symboliques et même pragmatique des
personnes privées qui relève
exclusivement du chef de l'état pour
assurer sa sécurité
on sait qu'on peut leur demander
éventuellement d'autres choses que
seulement jean pierre sueur puisqu'il
est au micro de tam traduit c'est à vous
oui jean pierre sueur à l'issue de ces
29 audition maintenant s'ouvre une phase
d'analysé notamment un de ces auditions
puis un certain nombre de pièces que
vous avez demandé comment est ce que
vous envisagez cette période avec
sérénité sérieux sans complaisance et en
toute indépendance d'esprit
quelles que soient les commentaires
éventuels pression nous serons un
indépendant et nous avons maintenant un
matériau très riche que d'ailleurs tous
les français ont pu voir puisque je ne
sais pas combien ça fait deux heures
d'audition ça devait faire ces pas 30 ou
40 heures même largement plus de
toussaint quand je ne sais pas je
racontais donc il ya eu beaucoup de
déclarations
il est clair qu'il y à des
contradictions il est clair qu on a le
sentiment d'un puzzle dont les pièces ne
s'emboîtent pas
ne semblait pas totalement ou parfois ne
s'emboîtent pas du tout certains disent
il faudrait presque rien auditionné tout
le monde tellement il ya une
contradiction entre les témoignages on
va voir rien est exclu mais je crois que
pour le moment on va travailler
donc quel est notre rôle d'abord eux
nous sommes nous ne sommes pas un
tribunal donc d'une cour mais non
personne ne sait pas notre boulot
nous sommes là pour trouver la vérité
pour trouver les dysfonctionnements qui
ont eu lieu pour trouver les causes des
dysfonctionnements et pour faire des
préconisations afin que ces
dysfonctionnements ne se renouvelle pas
tout simplement
vous savez une commission d enquête
parlementaire elle relève de la
constitution la constitution dit que la
fonction d'une commission d'enquêté
parlementaire
c'est premièrement 2 contre les
gouvernements et deuxièmement d'évaluer
les politiques publiques
donc nous nous en tenons à ça nous
faisons cela le mieux que nous pouvons
le mieux que nous pouvons nous ne sommes
pas infaillibles
nous nous nous ouvrons avec sérieux nous
dirons dans certains cas notre intime
conviction
mais nous essaierons de faire le rapport
le plus honnête possible on répondait
quasiment là où les attaquants qu'il y
avait pu avoir déjà depuis plus ancienne
de l'exécutif au tour est bien de la
dimension politique de la commission
denquête est ce que peut-être s'il n'y a
pas de dimension politique je suis très
claire il n'y en a pas pour la bonne
raison que voyez-vous le président et
les deux co rapporteurs n'appartiennent
pas au même groupe politique cela ne
vous a pas échappé
tous les membres de la commission ont
posé des questions voyez que ce matin
encore il ya eu peut-être vingt
questions posées par des collègues
appartenant absolument tous les groupes
sans exception
donc nous ne sommes pas là pour faire
des oppositions politiques mais pour
ensemble assumer une tâche
il consiste à rechercher la vérité à
rechercher les dysfonctionnements et à
faire des préconisations aux services de
l'état au service de l'intérêt général
et de la république quand souhaitez vous
rendre votre rapport et quelle pièce
vous manque encore nous manque encore un
certain nombre de pièces que nous avons
sollicités et aussi il ya des pièces que
nous n'obtenons absolument pas nous le
mettrons dans le rapport lundi kron
notamment la fameuse fiche de passes
d'alexandre mène à la on en fera état si
on dira qu'on ne l'a pas obtenue alors
que monsieur mais là si je ne me trompe
pas c'était engagé à la fournir me
semble-t-il je ne peux pas l'affirmer à
commission denquête ne peut pas forcer
l'elysée a donné cette fiche de parité
nous avons écrit nous nous nous allons
leur demander les pièces que nous
n'avons pas pu obtenir
mais soyez sûrs que nous allons
continuer de travailler avec un grand
sérieux
excusez moi et comme nous travaillons
avec un grand sérieux
je ne peux pas vous dire quand nous
allons sortir le rapport ce ne sera pas
dans une éternité rassurez vous mais ce
sera dans un certain temps parce qu'il
nous faut du temps pour travailler et
bien merci beaucoup jean pierre mérat
sont vos larmes actions merci à bientôt
merci à vous attend pour cette réaction
directe suite de notre édition spéciale
vous le savez on revient ce matin et
bien sûr les travaux de la commission d'
enquête du sénat alain marc je vous
propose de réécouter une ambition qui
était aussi marquante il s'agit de celle
de michel delpech le préfet de police de
paris il rage et c'est justement à la
vidéo d'alexandre bénin la place de la
contrescarpe écouter mes réactions en
interne pour faire vite je demande
immédiatement à la direction de l'ordre
public et de la circulation est pourquoi
et comment il était là sachant que
j'avais été très étonné la veille au
soir de croiser monsieur benalla dans la
salle de commandement où j'avais
accueilli deux ministres mais c'est en
faisant le tour d'être là étonné je fais
tu es sur le terrain voilà la réponse
que j'ai eu et très vite
le direct immédiatement le directeur de
l'ordre public et de la circulation m'a
dit je n'étais pas informé du fait que
monsieur benalla était ce jour là dans
nos rangs nous cherchons à établir des
dysfonctionnements qui sont exactement
ce que en creux vous décrivez c'est à
dire un collaborateur du président de la
république qui parce qu'ils les
collaborateurs du président de la
république avec un grand sentiment
d'impunité
détenteur d'une carte parée de bleu de
blanc et de rouge croit pouvoir prendre
la place des fonctionnaires de police ou
de gendarmerie qui assurent une
opération de maintien de l'ordre et
abuse de l'autorité qui l'exercent
naturellement et de fait auprès de
fonctionnaires de rang modeste en
s'imposant à eux et c'est ceci qui pour
nous est le plus intolérable du point de
vue non seulement de l'état de droit
mais du respect des valeurs de la
république je rappelle que ce jour là de
toute façon
de toute façon il n'était pas du tout
dans le cadre de ses missions il était
comme observateurs donc la faute
la faute est une faute c'est la sienne
c'est un manquement individuel avec
toutes ses conséquences la faute elle
est là la faute elle est là c'est c'est
pas le fait d'être présent qui est une
faute le fait d'être accueillis à la
préfecture de police à l'occasion d'un
service d'ordre
ce n'est pas une faute le fait
d'accueillir un collaborateur du
président de la république ce n'est pas
une faute
la faute c'est le comportement de la
personne sur le terrain une fois qu'on a
dit ça après on peut parler du reste on
voit là l'ennui de michel delpech c'est
une faute individuelle
je crois que c'était sans doute le
dérapage aussi individuelle mais cela
montré que la confiance du président qui
était placé dans cette danse garçon
était une confiance une confiance ne se
méritait absolument pas et ce en dit
long sur justement ce qu'a dit le
professeur tout à l'heure de la la
confiance qu'a le président pour
certaines institutions
et donc heureusement qu'il ya des
contre-pouvoirs dans ce pays
heureusement que la presse a sorti cette
affaire mais que à côté de cela il
existe
institutionnellement le sénat qui a
montré par son action qui n'est pas une
action comme celle qui va se dérouler au
niveau au niveau judiciaire mais qui au
niveau des institutions on va voir ce
qui a cloché
en gros parce que la sécurité du
président de la république que pouvait
être in fine et un jour atteintes par ce
type de personnage qui s'immisce dans un
dans un système institutionnel
alors bien sûr un jeune quelqu'un de de
26 ans qui qui probablement comme on le
dit vulgairement à a pété un câble parce
que cette personne là se sentait toute
puissante
bon c'est quelque chose c'est quelque
chose aussi à prendre en compte par les
institutions et donc c'est notre boulot
notre boulot de la commission d'une
enquête du sénat que de voir ces
dysfonctionnements de les mettre en
exergue et de faire en sorte que cela ne
se reproduise pas et ceci bien loin des
jeux politiciens que l'exécutif moment
donné a voulu mettre sur la table et
cela démontrait vraiment sa fébrilité
rappelez vous quand on nous a dit mais
de quoi se mêle le sénat et ses
tentations de politiser cette commission
enquête à nos marques de notre part il
n'y a pas eu de tentation de la
politiser mais je crois que c'est
l'attitude de l'exécutif qui a fait que
cette commission denquête est venu au
centre du jeu politique parce que qu'y
at il à cacher pour que la ministre de
la justice que le porte parole du
gouvernement et d'autres se mettent à
critiquer le sénat suk lee né ils sont
absolument pas de leur rôle d'ailleurs
oui moi ce qui me choque aussi c'est que
cette personne avait une arme alors elle
se disait en insécurité elle avait
besoin d'une arme alizay que de temps en
temps elle a pu venir auprès du
président avec cette arme c'est quand
même pas rien tout à l'heure
le commissaire a bien dit on voit quand
une personne porte une arme ça se voit à
son allure et on a laissé faire on a
laissé ce monsieur rentrer dans dans le
cercle très rapprochée du président avec
une arme alors mon collègue parle de
péter un plomb
ben c'est ce genre de personne ne sait
pas s'ils peuvent ou pas se servir de
l'armé
on n'a pas là les officiers du j espère
fonder thèse qui fondent et des
entraînements ils ont une surveillance
psychologique une surveillance de
compétences extraordinaires ce qu'on
leur impose et ce monsieur en fin de
compte on sait pas ce qu'il est capable
de faire et un deuxième point aussi que
qui m'interpelle c'est le fait que tout
ça soit arrivé jusqu'à nous par un
enregistrement privé par smartphone ça
paraît irréel on a l'impression d'être
dans un film que quelqu un film avec un
smartphone et comme ça arrive jusqu'à
nous il a fallu ça pour qu'on le sache
c'est quand même impressionnant alors
justement jeu proposant de revoir une
partie dans des conditions d'alexandre
benalla compte il s'explique sur sa
fonction auprès des chefs de l'état
écoutez je suis au regret de vous dire
je n'étais pas le garde du corps
d'emmanuel macron je n'ai jamais été le
garde du corps d'emmanuel macro à partir
du moment où vous êtes dans une tâche
vous faites l'interface entre le
candidat et un certain nombre de
personnes ou vous êtes un facilitateur
moi j'avais une tâche d'organisation
générale de sécurité générale mais sur
des meetings
j'étais proche de lui physiquement et on
l'a vu dans les médias mais comme un
certain nombre de personnes sur lequel
on porte pas le focus aujourd'hui vous
avez cette notion vous avez besoin de
cette proximité pour lui passer un
certain nombre de messages mais je
n'étais pas les gardes du corps
d'emmanuel m'accroche et je ne les ai
jamais été et pour être répond de
manière très claire
j'avais quatre missions à l'elysée m ma
première mission était l'organisation
des déplacements nationaux dans le cadre
de ce que je viens de vous expliquer la
force que vous en aviez déjà
connaissance il est l organisation d
événements au palais dans le cadre de ce
que je viens de vous expliquer là
également et dont vous aviez
connaissance il était le cadre
l'organisation et je vais employer le
terme parce qu'on appelle les
déplacements privés du président de la
république je pourrais m'en expliquer si
vous avez des questions là-dessus et il
était dans une tasse dans une tâche par
donc on l'a appelée coordination des
services de sécurité la coordination des
services de sécurité je pense vous avoir
expliqué le par mon parcours j'ai une
petite connaissance du domaine de la
sécurité il consistait pas à être le
chef de la sécurité de l'elysée il
consistait à conduire un certain nombre
de réunions de réflexion souvent si vous
prenez le colonel lavergne qui est
maintenant général qui a besoin de 12
voitures supplémentaires par exemple
pour son parc automobile
s'il n'a pas un appui politique si le
cabinet n'aide pas c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne si le cabinet ne l'aide pas
il pourra aller demander 12 voitures au
ministère de l'intérieur
il sera tout seul face au ministère de
l'intérieur et c'est souvent ce qui se
passe donc par exemple j'avais en charge
le renouvellement du parc automobile de
l'elysée
parce qu'à un moment vous êtes vous fait
des réunions à un autre niveau que deux
chefs de service administration centrale
vous faites une réunion un niveau
cabinet c'est à dire le cabinet du
président de la république saisi le
cabinet du ministre l'intérieur parce
qu'il a besoin de moyens supplémentaires
ce n'était pas une fonction
opérationnelle de sécurité c'était une
fonction administrative
je suis un peu dans l'esprit du
président c'est que quand on me demande
de faire quelque chose je le fais je
vais un peu jusqu'au bout et parfois
vous attirer des inimités de gens qui
vous explique que ça fait 40 ans qu'on
fait comme ça et qu'on vous a pas
attendu pour changer les choses
bah ça peut créer des tensions parfois
et quand vous faites pas partie du club
excusez moi de l'expression et ben on
vous le reproche
doni bérenger on entend on a encore une
fois alexandre b n'a pas de fonctions
administratives une détail ce qui la
faisait auprès du chef de l'état ont
parlé de beaucoup de zones d'ombré de
contradictions finalement cette
commission denquête parce qu'elle aura
permis d'en savoir un peu plus tard mme
tran il nous faisait l'instant les
sénateurs attendent sur la fiche de
poste d'alexandre menin
oui je pense qu'ils peuvent attendre un
certain temps un petit peu comme la
feuille d'impôt de monsieur trump s'est
pas certain qu'elle arrive dans le débat
public rapidement peut-être parce
qu'elle existait pas je ne sais pas
il a qualifié pour le dire cette
commission denquête elle a quand même un
résultat positif c29 audition ils nous
en ont appris beaucoup sur l'état sur la
présidence de la république sur le
fonctionnement de la préfecture de
police dans ses différentes missions au
niveau de commandement mais aussi
comment est-ce qu'on délivre un permis
de port d'armes comment est-ce qu'il est
demandé beaucoup beaucoup de matériaux
qui est intéressant qui est intéressant
pour l'opinion publique pour les
spécialistes des gens comme moi en
savent beaucoup plus maintenant sur le
fonctionnement de l'état qu'avant au
total pour fonctionne en particulier
cela dit une chose sur la vème
république
c'est qu'en réalité c'est le premier
ministre qui est censé être le chef de
l'administration c'est le gouvernement
qui est censé disposer de
l'administration en réalité avec l'hyper
présidentialisation le résultat que nous
avons c'est que c'est l'elysée qui
décide du fonctionnement de
l'administration
alors ça les institutions ne sont pas
faites pour l'horloge de l'état n'est
pas fait pour qui un rouage qui aille de
la présidence aux différents ministères
voire même à des fonctionnaires
subordonnés or c'est ça qui se passe
c'est ça qui se passe c'est que on sait
très bien qu'en réalité un conseiller
d'élise et il a plus de pouvoir
probablement que tel ou tel ministre que
monsieur strzoda ou que monsieur colère
est en réalité plus puissant que tel ou
tel ministre ou secrétaire d'état
je pense que c'était peut-être pas
claire pour l'opinion avant la sphère
benalla et que même si on met de côté
tous les aspects de faits divers ou la
personnalité des différents intervenants
ce qui s'est passé et place de la
contrescarpe etc etc
on sait maintenant que cette
présidentialisation extrême de l'état
elle fait dysfonctionné l'administration
ça je pense que les différentes
différents membres de cette commission
philippe bas qui a été secrétaire
général de l'elysée les gens qui
connaissent très bien l'état ont été
frappés par ça
il ya un danger de déstabilisation la
petite étincelle benalla pu faire
dysfonctionné pratiquement toute
l'administration
cette analyse fait rose et je suis
d'accord pour ce cas particulier mais je
pense qu'il ne faut pas faire d'un cas
particulier une généralité et oui la
sphère benalla a montré un
dysfonctionnement incontestablement on
l'a dit maintenant je ne suis pas
convaincu que ce que révèle la sphère
benalla et que ça se passe toujours
comme ça depuis 40 ans je n'ai jamais eu
l'honneur de participer au cabinet du
président je ne sais pas de l'intérieur
comment ça marche mais j'en ai quelques
connaissances notamment son quinquennat
précédent et ce qui était en charge des
déplacements privés du chef de l'état
n'était pas à ma connaissance sans
révéler des secrets d'état
des personnes qui n'étaient pas des
officiers de police
ensuite effectivement la sphère benalla
révèle un dysfonctionnement de
l'administration
au niveau sécurité je suis pas certain
qu'on puisse en faire une généralité sur
toutes les administrations de la
république et moi je suis toujours assez
réservé sur ce qualificatif d'hyper
présidentialisation du régime toujours
pris le contre-pied de cela oui nous
avons un président puissant mais il est
il bénéficie de la légitimité politique
et populaire pour ce faire on voit aussi
à quel point ce président puissant et
parfois impuissants et venir ce qui se
passe
pas plus tard qu'aujourd'hui même le
confirme un vrai j'ai clairement oui
tout à l'heure quand même le commissaire
nous a dit que elle n'a jamais été
confronté à ce genre de situation que
c'est à sa connaissance la première fois
que ça arrive puisque elle elle n'a
jamais eu et elle n'aurait pas accepté
mon empiète sur son pouvoir de
protection
elle l'a bien dit et rappelé tout à
l'heure on voit ces zones d'ombré ses
contradictions dont on parle et on va
raconter justement les différents
protagonistes
les personnes auditionnées qui apporte
bien chacune à leur façon des éléments
sur la fonction d'alexandre benalla à
commencer par françois-xavier lauch
écouter
la coordination des deux services la
coordination et c'est comme ça que nous
l'avons voulue sous l'autorité du
directeur de cabinet donc pas la mienne
la coordination des deux services de
sécurité de l'elysée
le j'espèrais le commandement militaire
en quoi consistait cette coordination
parce que vous allez me poser la
question très simplement nous avons vu
en arrivant au palais de l'elysée que
deux services de sécurité se côtoyer que
sur des sujets très qui n'ont rien à
voir d'ailleurs avec l'exercice de
prérogatives de sécurité il y avait une
meilleure coexistence a organisé entre
les missions de monsieur benalla rentrer
dans le cadre fixé par le législateur
ainsi considérant l'action d'alexandre
benalla de coordination de sécurité de
la présidence de la république avec les
forces militaires et le gspr considérant
qu'il exerçait sa mission auprès du
président de la république qui fait
l'objet de nombreuses menaces et dans un
contexte au niveau de menace terroriste
n'a jamais été aussi élevé et
considérant qu'ils étaient de fait
manifestement exposés à des risques
d'agression
c'est ça qui est écrit dans l'arrêté le
préfet de police a validé sa demande et
j'ai signé le 13 octobre 2017 par
délégation du préfet de police
l'autorisation de port d'armes de
monsieur benalla une autorisation que
nous avons limité strictement à
l'exercice de ses missions et à la
validité de son contrat à la présidence
de la république
je n'ai que des que des retours positifs
sur son engagement et son dévouement et
je pense et le président république
s'est exprimé sur ce sujet hier est
effectivement qui fait écho à
un élément que fait valoir alexander des
nanas sur le fait c'était quelqu'un qui
avait un profil différent et c'est tout
à fait vrai qu alexandre dellal a un
profil différent par rapport au type de
profil qu'on rencontre fréquemment dans
les couloirs de l'elysée je pense que
c'est aussi cette pause en apnée qui a
dit que c'était quelque chose ne pouvait
être fier parce que c'est important
aussi que les services la présence d'un
public soit à l'image de notre pays et
le fait que mais qu' il est il et il est
un profil evian ce qui est ce qui est en
revanche important c'est que chacun
reste dans le cadre de ses
responsabilités à la remarque
la question du port d'armé on voit bien
elle pourrait symboliser la complaisance
ou alexandre ménard a pu faire l'objet
je peux revenir sur ce qu'a dit monsieur
loches ça devienne un contrat d'1 totale
contradiction avec ce que vient de dire
madame at il n'y avait aucun problème
or on la vend entre le gspr et le
commandement militaire et là j'ai
l'impression que les gens que nous avons
auditionné le secrétaire général etc
sont en train de justifier l'emploi de
monsieur benalla en disant qu'il y avait
des problèmes entre le gsp et le
commandement militaire
ça me parait a posteriori et après avoir
entendu de madame madame à tout à
l'heure
complètement en contradiction et donc
c'est assez
avec un petit peu d'humour je dirais que
c'est même risible de les entendre
aujourd'hui a posteriori en train de se
justifier avec des éléments de langage
qui ferait que ce benalla ils pouvaient
pouvoir pourquoi pas à travers les
propos appartenir à la diversité etc
serait quelqu'un qu'il faudrait
introduire nager pour quoi justifier à
tout prix du fait que quelqu'un jeunes
généraliserait à d'ailleurs dit à mac
lorsque je lui posais la question c'est
la première fois qu'on octroyé le grade
de lieutenant-colonel à quelqu'un
d'aussi jeune même si c'est provisoire
et dans le cadre de la réserve
il y avait des tas d'éléments qui font
que je pense tout simplement que
monsieur benalla avait été imposée par
l'elysée au chef de cabinet ça
transparaît quand même assez nettement
aujourd'hui quand on revoit les
quand on revoit les auditions et qu'on
essaie de justifier pratiquement à tout
prix sa présence qui était finalement un
obstacle à la sécurité réelle du
président de la république mais moi
c'est même si c'est pas une affaire
d'état et on peut justifier de moins
travailler sur cet élément
il ya des choses qui sont quand même
beaucoup plus importante pour moi
aujourd'hui et reliés à l'actualité
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas si on va y
revenir tout à l'heure le professeur et
l'autre professeur aussi l'on dit je
crois que c'est quelque chose qui est
important aujourd'hui dans la difficulté
aussi qu'à l'exécutif à constituer un
gouvernement
est ce que l'on a vu là procède aussi de
ses difficultés alors baranger la
difficulté aussi à la commission
bancaire du sénat
ça aura été de ne pas empiéter sur la
justice on rappelle que des personnes
mais en examen ont été entendus est-ce
que la haye la sela est resté justement
dans son rôle écoutez la ministre de la
justice madame belloubet s'était
inquiété du risque d'empiètement sur la
séparation des pouvoirs
qu'est ce qu'on a pu constater que
jamais à aucun moment la moindre
question n'a été posée par un quelconque
sénateurs et sénatrices qui aurait
empiété sur l' enquête judiciaire donc
le risque ne s'est pas concrétisée bien
au contraire la séparation des pouvoirs
elle a été protégée elle a été bien
utilisé par le sénat dans ses fonctions
de contrôle politique et de et de
contre-pouvoirs si on regarde par
exemple les questions qui ont été posées
à monsieur collomb ou à monsieur strzoda
voie monsieur colère on constate que
c'était des questions précises factuel
mais que ces questions là a précisé
factuel les ont déstabilisé et leur ont
posé des problèmes je pense que ça a été
un mauvais moment pour monsieur collomb
cette audition il était en difficulté
il était en retrait pareil pour monsieur
colère pareil pour monsieur strzoda qui
se sont révélés être des sortes de quasi
nice ne vont tout à fait puissant au
sein d'états mais si vous les connaissez
pas donc arretez il n'y a pas eu de
danger pour l'enquêté judiciaire je les
vois paris se sont pas matérialisées et
du point de vue de la séparation des
pouvoirs je pense que le sénat a été
dans son rôle de contrôle politique r je
sois un monde avant de vous donner à
parler des roses et on va ré coûter
aussi à la façon dont les personnes
auditionnées se présenter toutes les
personnes appartement
à l'élysée puisqu'elles ont toutes
rappeler et bien qu'elle avait été
autorisée par le chef de l'état à venir
s'exprimer devant le sénat et coûter le
président de la république en autorisant
à venir devant vous a souhaité à
contribuer à la manifestation de la
vérité
le président de la république a autorisé
certaines ses collaborateurs à venir
devant vous afin de contribuer à la
manifestation de la vérité
le président de la république m'a
autorisé à venir devant vous tout
citoyen qui est convoqué par une
commission d' enquête parlementaire doit
déférer à la convocation
c'est tout nul n'est au dessus des lois
à cet égard les gens viennent de reggae
ska années cette séquence on voit bien
justement chacun est bien se justifier
ils ont été autorisés à venir par le
chef de l'état est donc bien sûr il a
rappelé toute personne doit venir
s'exprimer devant une commission
d'enquêté sur la rappeler le président
philippe bas avait eu l'occasion de le
rappeler aussi et ça relève même du
droit pénal c'est à dire quelqu'un qui
ne se présente pas et passible de deux
ans d'emprisonnement et de 7500 euros
damende ça montre que le seul qui peut y
échapper c'est le président la
république justement c'était un débat
qu'on avait eu au début de la de la
séquence ça montre que le président la
république voulait contrôler cette
commission denquête mais que précisément
le jeu de la séparation des pouvoirs
comme l'a très justement rappelé
professeurs parents j'ai le jeu de la
séparation des pouvoirs a montré que le
prix dans la république ne devait pas et
surtout ne pouvait pas contrôler cette
commission denquête qui relève du
parlement qui mène sa mission
conformément aux textes établis la
constitution et leur donne ans de 1958
elle n'empiète pas elle n'a jamais
empiéter dans le domaine judiciaire
si jamais elle avait posé une question à
monsieur benalla qu'il aurait mis en
difficulté par rapport à sa mise en
examen il aurait pu invoquer son droit
constitutionnel a gardé le silence
ce qu'il n'a pas eu à faire parce
qu'aucune question n'a été posée dans ce
sens et elle c'est cette commission
s'est cantonné à exercer son rôle
politique de contrôle de séparation des
pouvoirs et la séparation des pouvoirs
ce n'est pas seulement et ce n'est pas
tant l'isolation des pouvoirs
distinction des pouvoirs que le contrôle
d'un pouvoir sur l'autre et cela me
permet de revenir sur un point que l'on
a abordé en début de cette émission la
commission denquête a toujours été
politique depuis le départ elle n'est
rien d'autre que politique on est au
parlement une institution politique et
la commission denquête mène un rôle
politique et certainement pas judiciaire
là encore ça a été rappelé par ses
membres ils ne vont condamner personne
ils sont là pour faire la lumière sur
des fêtes jusqu'au plus haut niveau de
l'état cette commission denquête malgré
tout mais oui mais elle ne vaut pas
comparution ça a été dit et redit du
début la séparation des pouvoirs a été
vraiment extrêmement respectée on était
tous les membres de cette commission
très vigilants à ne pas empiéter sur
justement le processus judiciaire
libre aux juges de faire ce qu'il veut
maintenant avec les éléments nous ce qui
nous importait c'est de savoir si le
chef de l'état que ce soit monsieur
malraux un autre était bien protégé en
france et que si on avait mis tout en
oeuvre pour respecter ce qui était
existants et qu'on n'ait pas à déroger
comme sa dernière minute sur un coin de
table de savoir qui fait quoi cc c'est
absolument impossible
alain marc la tentation allait peut-être
là aussi pour la majorité sénatoriale
d'égratigner
et non il y à ce que c'est ce que révèle
cette histoire mais aussi sur la révèle
au niveau des comportements et il est
normal comme l'a dit le professeur que
nous en tirions aussi des enseignements
politiques parce que quand même il ya
des faits il y a quand même l'exécutif
qui a essayé plusieurs fois de me dire
n'empiétait pas sur le domaine
judiciaire et c'est ce qu'ils n'avaient
pas affaire à des rôles ou tout
simplement de cette même séparation des
pouvoirs la pompe ce que vous en parlez
alors qu'on voir écouter un la garde des
sceaux
ainsi le porte-parole du gouvernement
benjamin griveaux est la réponse de
gérard larcher
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
cette commission denquête gère un
règlement de compte politique
je n'imagine pas alors je vais vous la
refusez reposer la question avec les
mots de benjamin griveaux qui voit qui a
l'impression que le sénateur philippe
bas est en train de faire une campagne
politique personnelle contre le
président république moi je reste sur le
plan des principes ce que je viens de
rappeler
il va de soi que personne n'est dupe de
ce qui se passe de ce qui s'est passé
cet été de l'instrumentalisation de ce
qui est tout de même une dérive au
départ personnel et il est va de soi
qu'il ya toujours une lecture politique
à chacun de ces âmes dont moi je
considère que lorsqu'on est président
d'une commission denquête sans doute est
il heureux de s'exprimer assez peu dans
la presse tant que la commission n'a pas
poursuivi ses travaux jusqu'à son terme
c'est la plus élémentaire des
déontologique d'être le président
impartiale d'une commission d' enquête
parlementaire et je sais moi le sérieux
ce qu'est une commission d enquête
parlementaire il en a eu des célèbres
dans l'histoire la république d'ailleurs
souvent composés en président d'un
membre de la majorité des membres de
l'opposition
je constate qu'il n'y a que des membres
de l'opposition qui préside cette
commission denquête gouvernement au
sénat n'était pas le cas à l'assemblée
nationale mais j'ai en mémoire ce soit
la commission cahuzac la commission
outreau souvenez vous ces travaux qui
avaient été portées sur une affaire
extrêmement délicate sensible difficile
et bien ou
les présentes s'exprime pas dans la
presse tant que les travaux n'avaient
pas été menées jusqu'à leur terme
je crois que c'est là aussi un code de
déontologie que chacun devrait
s'appliquer
il manque des d'anthologie et de
parcelles d'impartialité
quand on est président d'une commission
denquête on s'applique à soi-même
travail de notre réalité et puis à
l'issue des travaux de la commission
évidemment on est parfaitement libre de
s'exprimer mais ça c'est l'appréciation
personnelle de chacun et le rapport de
chacun un certain comportement éthique
et moral monsieur bona est convoqué il a
des propos déplacés offensant parce que
vous n'avez pas traduit quelques autres
propos à l'égard des sénateurs du
président est un président ion et
philologue mission je dois dire que
regarder vous regardez les travaux de la
commission en juillet moi je vais vous
dire je laisserai pas je ne laisserai
pas insulter l'institution qu'est le
sénat mais en même temps la commission
elle est totalement souveraine
c'est elle qui écoutera entendra et des
chinois mais quand même les mots sont
forts vous dites petits marquis philippe
bas mais quand même pour vous hein vous
que vous vous sentez au dessus des lois
côté la leçon du respect de la loi par
monsieur benalla pardonnez moi de vous
dire on passera je ne laisserai pas je
ne laisserai pas insulter l'institution
de tension de pression cette commission
enquête
gérard larcher a complètement raison
mais pour qui se croit monsieur grille
vous jeu il y à un moment où justement
la séparation des pouvoirs fait qu'il
n'aurait qu'il aurait dû se taire sur le
sujet et nous laisser travailler parce
que quand on regarde le climat dans
lequel
se passe cette cette commission cette
mission d enquête avec philippe bas à la
tête c'est quelque chose de très
courtois avec des questions qui ne sont
jamais dérangeante offensant dont on va
vers les faits donc ce que dit monsieur
rivaux c'est absolument offensants et
c'est ça qui a relancé
l'aspect politique les gens ne
supportent plus que des gens viennent
nous faire la leçon
nous ne supportons pas en tant que
sénateur et les français ne supportent
pas d'autant que ce monsieur qui donne
des leçons de morale essaie de couvrir
monsieur monsieur monsieur biya la scala
pas joli quand même ce qu'a dit monsieur
b dallas c'est quelque chose qui est
habituel on s'excuse pour après mieux
passer auprès des gens qui vont
démissionner c'est quelque chose qui est
usa ça sent la peur pour le climat de
tensions à venir finalement devant moi
suite à ce qu'on vient de voir là quand
on entend des riffs personnelle de
monsieur benalla pourquoi pas alors
pourquoi pas l'avoir dit tout de suite
si c'était si simple et si c'était si
ordinaire que ça pourquoi avoir fait
tant de de cinéma autour de ça parce que
moi je trouve que c'était du cinéma
souvenez vous quand même le président de
la république autour de ses députés en
marche de dire qu'il vienne me chercher
non mais tout ça ça fait qu' on est
l'opinion publique a dû se dire mais on
est dans une pièce de théâtre alors que
c'était tout simplement savoir ce qui se
passait tout simplement oui moi ce qui
m'a le plus frappé dans cette séquence
c'est le propos du ministre des
relations avec le parlement
ce questionnaire qui a parlé d'une
tentative de destitution du président de
la république
ça m'a frappée parce que ça n'était pas
en phase avec la teneur des discussions
qui avaient lieu dans cette commission
et parce que ça traduit une conception
des fonctions de ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement
un petit peu singulière ça traduit je
sais pas comment dire exactement mais
une certaine conception verticale ou la
verticalité des rapports avec le
parlement
on est dans un contexte où sans faire de
politique fiction on a un gouvernement
qui a du mal à être remaniée qui est un
petit peu fragilisé politiquement alors
qu'il à 314 députés d'une majorité à la
suite de la destitution de mou
destitution et vient de la constitution
il vient de l'article 68 et d'une
procédure qui permet éventuellement en
cas d'une inconduite magistrale et grave
du président lui-même de le destituer
s'était pas je crois le sujet mais je
pense même qu'il y avait il ya aucun
risque parce que le nom même du
président était très peu prononcé dans
cette commission son rôle n'est pas en
cause et il y avait une différence
d'échelle entre la réaction de
l'exécutif je ne suis pas là pour dire à
l'exécutif ce qui doit faire mais ça
semble pas avoir été dans son intérêt de
faire ça si vous voulez un sénateur qui
avait été ici sur un des plateaux avait
dit le mieux qu'ils auraient pu faire
c'est de ne rien dire du tout mais en
réalité c'est ce que je suis tenté de
penser voilà oui je vais repartir de ce
que disait monsieur griveaux qui
prétendait avoir une connaissance de
grande commission denquête je crois
qu'il ya quelque chose qui a échappé à
sa connaissance c'est que en france il
ya deux chambres au parlement
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat à
l'assemblée nationale il ya eu une
tentative de commission denquête avec un
membre de la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale et dont de la majorité
gouvernementale
la présidente lydia et lebron pie v et
un membre de l'opposition le rapporteur
guillaume larrivé elle a explosé en
plein vol parce que précisément je crois
que la déontologie peut-être questionné
il y a eu des blocages très net de la
part de la présidente de la commission
des lois
ici au sénat il y à un membre de la
majorité sénatoriale
le président philippe bas et le
rapporteur muriel jourda et un membre de
l'opposition sénatoriale premier parti
d'opposition le parti socialiste avec
jean pierre sueur comme co rapporteurs
tout cela est parfaitement conforme aux
traditions aux conventions établies dans
la constitution et la commission
denquête au sénat poursuit ses travaux
précisément parce que son président
philippe bas c'est prendre la hauteur et
la distance nécessaire vis-à-vis de des
aléas et et des mouvements de la
politique ne se laisse pas influencer
par les harangues de certains
responsables politiques que ce soit
monsieur griveaux le président la
république lui-même qui va jusqu'à
téléphoner avec gérard h f c'est quand
même un événement particulièrement
exceptionnelle dans l'histoire la vème
république sur ce sujet là je suppose
qu'ils se parlent assez régulièrement
mais que le président appelle le
président larcher sur les conclusions de
la commission d'enquêté sénatoriale
je vous propose de réécouter et bien
robert badinter l'ancien garde des
sceaux qu était l invité la semaine
dernière de rebecca fitoussi pour lui et
bien cette affaire le medal à n'être en
rien une affaire d'état écouter ne
confondons pas s'il vous plaît les
niveaux moi quand j'entends parler d'une
affaire propos sur l'avenir sourit
quelle affaire quoi comment jeu cissé
l'a examiné enquête mais vraiment quand
on considère je les dis que je vais
penser depuis vomir environ les affaires
les affaires dette
les jeux guézy connu mais je les ai vus
quand leader de l'opposition marocaine
et attiré dans un piège entre services
secrets assassiné en france et que son
corps est expédié en avion au maroc
là c'est une affaire d'état était hors
sac chic et la rupture de relations
diplomatiques dont greenpeace et vous
grande nouvelle zélande des forces
françaises appartenant à l'armée
française viennent pourquoi pour faire
un attentat et faire couler le bateau de
greenpeace toi là vous êtes dans une
affaire d'état pourquoi parce que les
pouvoirs de l'état s'en détournent je
dois faire je le reconnais ça n'est que
ça ce n'est pas une affaire d'état dans
la mesure où les pouvoirs de l'état
n'ont pas agi à l'encontre de leurs
devoirs de leurs limites
alors marc ce n'est pas une affaire un
des tanneries robert badinter
maintenant il va falloir voir où vous
souhaitez en tant que sénateur ayant
appartenu à cette commission denquête
placer le curseur
jusqu'où aller vous allez dans la
dénonciation justement de cette
différence dysfonctionnements à de
l'elysée d'abord j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour robert badinter et je suis
d'accord avec lui ce n'est absolument
pas une affaire d'état simplement qui ce
qui fait que ça devient une affaire
d'état c'est l'exécutif par son
comportement on vient de le dire quand
même que le professeur l'a dit tout à
l'heure quand le président de la
république et téléphone à gérard larcher
pour que nous donner des conseils sur le
fait qu'il ne faut pas empiéter sur
l'enquêté judiciaire etc
comme madame b d'ougrée se fait le
relais de cette parole là que monsieur
griveaux dans les médias se répand c'est
là que ça devient sa cache quoi ça
clashe le fait que l'exécutif ça parte
quand même ça cache le fait que
l'exécutif est fébrile sur quelque chose
qui n'allait fonctionnement pardon
observer la machine mais comme l'a dit
fort bien dit d'ailleurs philippe bas et
jean pierre sueur comme l'on dit tous
les deux philippe bas j'aime bien sûr
nous allons l'analyser
aujourd'hui collationner toutes les
toutes les auditions mettre en exergue
les contradictions et surtout faire en
sorte que ce qui a été notre fil rouge
au départ la sécurité du président de la
république ne soit pas mise en danger
par des éléments qui ferait extérieure à
ce qui a déjà été institutionnalisé
depuis des années et donc c'est ce qui
nous importe nous le reste bon les gens
les gens peuvent peuvent parler peuvent
se mouvoir comme l'exécuter comme les
jeunes de l'exécutif
mais nous ce qui nous importe c'est cela
que le président de la république soient
à l'abri
désormais au sein des institutions et
que celle ci ne soit pas perturbée oui
on a connu quand même ces dernières
années des menaces terroristes en plus
il faut pas l'oublier
notre notre président de la république
et quand même quand même heure au coeur
de ces deux séries ce qu on ne peut pas
le don qu'il faut autour de lui des gens
extrêmement compétents c'est moi j'étais
universitaire toute ma vie les jeunes
qui passaient le concours de commissaire
de police je les ai vus travailler je
les ai vus acquérir ce concours vraiment
avec cugn a cité une fois qu'ils l'ont
ils sont entraînés ils sont bons il n'y
a pas mieux que ce genre de deux
personnes anonymement recruté pour
exercer regardons ce qu'on a entendu
robert badinter il a raison l'ancien
garde des sceaux veut voir dans quelques
centres relativiser l'impact direct
cette affaire mais c'est pas roulettes
dès le départ nous on était dans cet
état d'esprit
vous savez au scénar n'est pas dans le
dans le
tout de suite à monte à faire monter la
mayonnaise
on est toujours dans un climat de
sérénité la preuve en est on s'entend à
merveille avec nos collègues socialistes
ou indépendants ou autres parce qu'on a
cette vision de l'état en sang et or en
nous quelque part notre rôle de
contre-pouvoir comme ce professeur le
disais c'est pas de contre-pouvoirs pour
dire de d'exercer quelque chose de
négatif
c'est une surveillance dans tout les
conseils d'administration il ya deux
deux entités ici il ya deux deux
chambres qui ont ce rôle de nîmes
arranger la commission denquête
sénatoriales n'est pas allé au bout des
six mois
il fallait peut-être aussi en terminer
avec cette commission denquête qui on
l'a dit a certainement gêné au plus haut
c'est ce que j'aurais tendance à penser
je pense pas que ça soit dans l'intérêt
du sénat de continuer cette séquence
donc être trop longtemps l'essentiel a
été fait 29 audition c'est assez long
l'énergie du sénat a été employé à cela
maintenant elle doit s'employer à
d'autres choses
je pense que ce qu'on attend maintenant
c'est le rapport et qu'on verra si c'est
un rapport serein avec des pv très
informatif comme ils l'ont été
la contribution de cette affaire à la
vie de l'état maintenant moi je mets ça
en relation avec le grand enjeu à venir
qu'est la réforme des institutions de
qu'on attend janvier prochain on se
rappellera peut-être à cette occasion
que le sénat joue un rôle dans le
contrôle politique de l'exécutif qu'une
réduction trop grande des prérogatives
du parlement peut être dommageable à l'
équilibre des pouvoirs est que la
démocratie dépend aussi de la
possibilité pour un organe comme le
sénat qui n'a pas la possibilité
techniquement d'engager la
responsabilité du gouvernement en
réalité de le contrôler efficacement
oui moi depuis le début de cette affaire
j'ai l'impression de me retrouver face à
ce tableau de magritte qui dit ceci
n'est pas une pipe ceci n'est pas une
affaire d'état mais plus on avance et on
voit la fébrilité de l'exécutif
plus on a quand même l'impression d'être
face à la représentation de l'état parce
que si l'exécutif intervient à ce point
c'est que quand même des choses des
choses à cacher et quant à cette réforme
constitutionnelle elle a été la victime
collatérale de la sphère benalla au mois
de juillet je suis extrêmement réservé
sur les propos qu'a tenus le président
la république le 4 octobre dernier au
conseil constitutionnel nous assurant
qu'elle allait revenir sur dans le débat
politique et parlementaire
parce que l véhiculera toujours avec
elle cette affaire benalla tout va
dépendre de comment est ce que le
président la république s'en sort et
pour l'instant il n'est pas bien engagé
et vu la tension qu'il y a eu entre le
sénat et un exécutif avec cette affaire
je vois pas comment est-ce qu'ils
pourraient trouver l'espace politique
pour la ramener sur le premier plan du
débat parlementaire merci à vous gens
filment des rosés merci dany bar 11 et
merci à brigitte à l'ère des merci à
vous alain marc nous a raccompagné ce
matin lors de cette émission spéciale
fin de cette édition on se retrouve tout
à l'heure à 16h30 pour un nouveau c'est
la 360
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]